AND CONVENE THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS --
WE'RE TO CONVENE A SUBCOMMITTEE
OF THANK YOU SENATOR LEYVA.
AND FIRST OF FIRST UP IS A. B.
N. THIRTY SIX BY SOMEONE I WORK
[inaudible]
CURRY [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBER AND MEMBER.
I WILL START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEEAMENDMENT TO PERMIT
RATHER THAN REQUIRE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO ADMINISTER
A NEW VOTER OUT REACH GRANT
PROGRAM.
EVERY EFFORT WE MAKE TO REDUCE
BARRIERS BETWEEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES WILL ENCOURAGE
FULLER PARTICIPATION IN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
INCLUDING THE CENSUS.
AB TEN THIRTY SIX WILL REDUCE
BARRIERS TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PROCESS IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST IT REQUIRES THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO UPDATE REGULATIONS
DIRECTING COUNTY OFFICIALS. TO
DEVELOP VOTER OUTREACH PROGRAMS.
UNFORTUNATELY SOME COUNTIES HAVE
VERY LOW REGISTRATION REYES IN
SOME COUNTIES CLOSE 240% OF
ELIGIBLE ROAD VOTERS ARE NOT
REGISTERED.
SECOND AB TEN THIRTY SIX CREATES
A HIGH SCHOOL VOTER EDUCATION
PILOT PROGRAM AND YELLOW COUNTY.
THE PILOT WILL STUDY MARK
ELECTIONS OF HIGH SCHOOLS AND
YOLO COUNTY CONDUCTED WITH
OFFICIAL OFFICIAL ELECTIONS
EQUIPMENT LIKE VOTING MACHINES
AND BALLOTS.
THIS TYPE OF MARKET ELECTION IS
EFFECTIVE FOR TEACHING YOUNGER
GENERATIONS HOW TO CAST A BALLOT
SO THEY ARE EXCITED INCOMPETENT
WHEN THEY GO TO THEIR FIRST FULL.
RATING THIS PILOT WILL
LEGITIMIZE THE EFFORTS OF YOLO
COUNTY AND ENSURE THE RESULTS OF
THIS PROGRAM AND INFORM AND
IMPROVE MOCK ELECTION STATE WISE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ROAD AND WE HAVE IN OF A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT.
AND MY ANGER I'M A SILLY OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT APPRECIATE
THIS BILLS EFFORTS TO ENCOURAGE
YOUNG PEOPLE TO GET.
INSIDE AN EDUCATED ABOUT VOTING
THEY'RE OFTEN UNDER REPRESENTED
IN THE ELECTORATE SO GETTING
THEM THE KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED TO
SUCCEED EARLY ON IN VOTING WILL
HELP THEM BE FULL MEMBERS OF OUR
SOCIETY.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS BY THE GOAL.
SO YOU SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
ACTUALLY I WINNER IF YOU WILL
AYE WE'RE RIGHT RUN GO WITH THE
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA
SENSATION COURSE SELECTIONS
OFFICIALS.
WE ON FRIDAY TOOK A SUPPORT OF
ASK THE AUTHOR TO CONSIDER.
CHANGING THE LANGUAGE TO ARRIVE
FOR UNDER PERFORMING COUNTIES TO
CONSIDER WORKING WITH THE COUNTY
IN QUESTION TO DEVELOP A PROGRAM
RATHER THAN JUST FORCING A
PROGRAM ON THE COUNTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WINNERS.
COME ON UP
.
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
AND ARE WE OPPOSE A. B..
TEN THIRTY SIX OF A COUPLE OF
REASONS -- ONE THAT WHILE IT IS
DESIRABLE TO THOROUGHLY EDUCATE
OUR CHILDREN IN THE FUNDAMENTALS
OF SELF GOVERNMENT.
AND THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AS ADULTS
CITIZENS.
THESE TENANTS ARE ALREADY
CENTRAL G. U. S. HIGH SCHOOL IN
CIVICS GOVERNMENT CLASSES BOTH
REQUIRED FOR GRADUATION.
ENCOURAGING TEACHERS OF SUCH
COURSES TO STRENGTHEN THAT
PORTION OF THE CURRICULUM IS
REASONABLE AND DESIRABLE.
IMPOSING ANOTHER STRUCTURE
WITHIN THE SCHOOL FOR THAT
PURPOSE IS NOT.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROGRAM
OUTLINED IN AB TEN THIRTY SIX
WOULD INEVITABLY LEAD TO SCHOOL
WIDE PRE REGISTRATION DRIVES.
AND THERE'S NO PROTECTION IN A.
B. TEN THIRTY SIX TO ENSURE.
THAT OUR STUDENTS DO NOT BECOME
VICTIMS OF PEER PRESSURE OR
POLITICALLY POLITICAL
INDOCTRINATION.
BY A THIRTY FIGURES TO ARE
LIKELY TO BE ON OR ILL TRAINED.
IN THE SUBJECT THE DANGER OF
SUCH DRIVES HAS ALREADY BEEN
EXPOSED.
AS SCHOOLS ALL OVER THE STATE
HAVE REGISTERED STUDENTS WITH NO
TRAINING OR KNOWLEDGE OF HOW TO
PROTECT STUDENTS FROM
INAPPROPRIATE PRESSURE.
AND TO PROTECT THEIR PERSONAL
AND PRIVATE INFORMATION.
NON CITIZENS AN UNDER AGE
STUDENTS ARE BEING REGISTERED
AND THEREFORE HARM.
THE FORMER IN YOUR VOCAL BLADE
IF THEY ARE HERE LAWFULLY AND ON
THE PATH TO CITIZENSHIP.
A PLAN FOR USING THE SCHOOLS IN
SUCH A WAY SHOULD BE APPROACHED
WITH GREAT QUESTION.
UNTIL PROPER AND DETAILED PLANS
AND THE CURRICULUM CAN BE
DEVELOPED AND TRAINING CONDUCTED.
WE NEED TO SLOW DOWN FOR THE
PROTECTION OF OUR CHILDREN AND
IN THE MEANTIME.
CALIFORNIA'S SCHOOLS NEED TO
STRENGTHEN THE CIVICS GOVERNMENT
CURRICULUM AND ALLOW THE EXPERTS
IN THE FIELD. TO DO RIGHT BY
THEIR BUDDING ADULTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THERE'S OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. ELEVEN QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS IN ONE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN I'VE ARE CURRY --
IS EXCELLENT BILL -- MOTIVATING
YOUNG PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROCESS IT IS IS -- A VERY
GOOD THANK.
I'M I'M A STUDENT OF HISTORY
READING -- ABOUT THE WOMEN'S
SUFFRAGE MOVEMENT RIGHT NOW AND
I KNOW THAT THE EXACT SAME
ARGUMENTS WERE USED WITH RESPECT
TO WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE AS AS WE'RE
JUST POSED.
TURNS OUT THAT THAT WHOLE
WOMEN'S SUFFRAGE THING WORKED
OUT OKAY SO -- SO -- ANYWAY --
IF THERE'S A MOTION -- WE'VE.
ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- ASSEMBLY IS SOMEONE
KALRA AB.
FIFTY NINE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
AB FIFTY NINE BILLS UPON OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO INCREASE
OF THE CAN GAUGE WENT AND VOTER
TURNOUT AMONG YOUNG VOTERS.
BY ADDING COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES AS CONSIDERATIONS FOR
THE PLACEMENT OF BOTH CENTERS
AND VOTERS CHOICE ACT COUNTIES.
HAVING ACCESS TO BOOKS CENTER
CAN EASILY RESOLVED EVERY REASON
A PERSON MAY HAVE THE PREVENTS
THEM FROM CASTING A BALLOT.
WITH A MOVED FORGOT TO REGISTER
LOS ARE BALLOT BUSY ON TUESDAYS
ARE JUST ON HAVE STANCE THEY CAN
ALL BE SOLVED BY VISITING ABOUT
CENTER.
COLLEGE CAMPUSES ARE UNIQUELY
SUITED TO HOST VOTE CENTERS
BECAUSE THEIR HOME TO EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLDS.
AND AGE GROUP THAT HISTORICALLY
TURNS OUT TO VOTE AT VERY LOW
RATES.
BUT BRING ABOUT SENATOR THEM IN
MAKING THESE SERVICES READILY
AVAILABLE WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS
ON THE PERPLEXING CHALLENGER
INCREASING TURNOUT AMONG THIS
VOTING DEMOGRAPHIC.
AB FIFTY NINE EMPOWERS ENGAGES
YOUNG PEOPLE WHICH WILL IN TURN
DECREASED THE DISPLAY DECREASES
DISPROPORTIONAL REPRESENTATION
VOTER TURNOUT.
AND MOVE US TOWARD A MORE ACTIVE
DEMOCRACY.
BY SUPPORTING TESTIMONIES NOEL
MORE FROM CSU SACRAMENTO AND
SHOULD BE NO TANKS IN EVERGREEN
DOLLARS BECAUSE COLLEGE GRADUATE
AN INCOMING SOUND A STATE
STUDENT.
WOULD ALSO SHARE WHY IS NOT JUST.
FOR THE YOUNGER DEMOGRAPHIC OF
STUDENTS BUT FOR ALL STUDENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SOME WOMEN KALRA -- THOSE IN
SUPPORT.
NOT NOT ALL AT ONCE.
THERE YOU GO NO GO HEAD.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING TO A
TERM BERG AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ON MY NAME IS NO MORE I AM THE
IMMEDIATE PAST PRESIDENT.
OF THE ASSOCIATED STUDENTS AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AS WELL AS A
FORMER CULT STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION BOARD MEMBER.
I FIRST OF THE JUST LIKE TO
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP ON THIS CRITICAL
ISSUE OF VOTER ACCESS AND CIVIC
RIGHTS.
AND I'M READY TO ATTEST TO THE
IMPORTANCE AND EXCITEMENT OF
HAVING A VOTE CENTER ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS.
I HAVE TO SAY THAT FOR STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF -- THE PRESSURES OF
OF A LIFE AND PROFESSIONAL
ACTIVITIES -- HAVING FIVE FULL
CLASSES AND THE JOB DO START TO
CATCH UP WITH YOU -- AND SIT IN
FULL DISCLOSURE I ALWAYS HAD MY
PARENTS DROP OFF MY BILL BY MAIL
BALLOT FOR ME -- FOR THESE EXACT
REASONS.
SO I WANT.
TO EMPHASIZE HOW I'M HAVING JUST
A BREAK IN BETWEEN YOUR CLASSES
OR HAVING THE EXTRA TIME AT THE
END OF THE DAY.
AND OF COURSE WE KNOW -- VOTE
CENTERS WILL BE OPEN FOR
MULTIPLE DAYS ON AT A TIME CAN
MAKE ALL THE DIFFERENCE WHEN
IT'S RIGHT THERE.
AND IT'S WAITING FOR YOU SO THAT
YOU CAN GO AND EXERCISE THIS
FUNDAMENTAL CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
THESE BOTH CENTERS PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS AND
CAMPUS COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN
THEIR ENTIRETY TO PARTICIPATE IN
EVERY SINGLE ELECTION.
IT'S A COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO
HAVE COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
COORDINATE ON THIS TYPE OF AN
EFFORT WITH OUR PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES.
HONORABLE MEMBERS.
I THINK THIS IS HOW IS BEGIN TO
TACKLE THE CHALLENGES RELATED TO
VOTER APATHY.
AND ACCESS ESPECIALLY AMONG
YOUNGER VOTERS BUT AGAIN FOR AN
ENTIRE CAMPUS COMMUNITY.
I WANT TO MENTION THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO BUILD COMMUNITY AROUND
OUR VOTE CENTER AS WELL.
I COULD GO ON DAYS AND DAYS WITH
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE DID BUT
I'M IN AND THAT'S SINCE WE HAD
STUDENT RUN ABOUT IT'S LIKE A
BLACK AND BROWN VOTER SUMMIT.
AND A NOT VOTING IS GERRY THEME
DUTCH OCCASIONAL FAIR WHICH WE
HAD A LOT OF FUN WITH -- AND WE
WORKED IN COLLABORATION WITH
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENT GROUPS
BY OUR BLACK STUDENT UNION OUR
STUDENTS FOR QUALITY EDUCATION --
AND OTHER STUDENT GROUPS GREEK
LIFE I'M AND MANY MORE.
ARE POINTS OF PRIDE ACTUALLY
INCLUDE HAVING THE MOST SAME DAY
VOTER REGISTRATIONS OF ALL VOTE
CENTERS IN THE ENTIRE STATE.
I'M AND BALLOTS CASTED WE ALSO
HAD TWO THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOTS DROPPED OFF.
AND YOU CAN ASK ANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE ALSO JUST GOOGLE
ALL THE NEWS REPORTS WE HAD
PEOPLE THERE UNTIL CLOSE TO
ELEVEN PM.
POLL WORKERS WANTED TO GO HOME.
BUT AGAIN UNDERSCORES -- THIS
ALL UNDERSCORES THE WILLINGNESS
AND EXCITEMENT THAT STUDENTS HAD
AND THE COMMUNITY HAD AND I'VE
SEEN THESE BENEFITS.
I'M A FOR THIS TYPE OF AN
ENDEAVOR FIRSTHAND THE IMPACT
YOU CAN HAVE FOR THOUSANDS.
AND MST IMPORTANTLY.
I'VE FELT THE SHIFT IN ATTITUDES.
FROM MY PEERS AND THAT IS AN
INDESCRIBABLE FEELING.
I'M IT MAKES A LOT A MAKES.
VOTING A CELEBRATION RATHER THAN
A TASK.
SO I STRONGLY URGE YOU FOR THESE
EASONS TO SUPPORT AND VOTE YES
ON A. B.. FIFTY NINE FOR THE
SAKE OF CONTINUING THIS PROGRESS
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME [inaudible]
OR GOOD MORNING MY NAME ASSURING
THAT TANK SEND I JUST RECENTLY
GRADUATED FROM SAN JOSE EVER
EVERGREE VALLEY COLLEGE
DISTRICT THIS PAST ME -- I AM A
SINGLE MOM OF FOUR CHILDREN ONE
OF WHICH IS IN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE OF
INDIANA.
AND I HAVE THREE SMALL CHILDREN
AT HOME I'M ALSO A VETERAN I'VE
SERVED IN THE AIR FORCE.
AND DO YOU KNOW GRADUATING.
AT FORTY FOUR YEARS YOUNG A
THREE YEAR WITH THREE WITH A
THREE YEAR OLD A SEVEN YEAR OLD
AND TEN YEAR OLD IS VERY
DIFFICULT.
A IT POSES A LOT OF BARRIERS FOR
ME BUT I DID IT.
AND I JUST WANNA TELL YOU ABOUT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I
REFLECTED ON WHILE I WAS IN
EVERGREEN VALLEY COLLEGE ONE OF
THOSE.
MOMENTS OF MY LIFE WAS STUDENT
ELECTIONS I WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT AT THE TIME AND I
FOUND THAT THERE WERE SO MANY
CHALLENGES FOR ME AS A CANDIDATE.
THE GOAL IN KANSAS CLASSROOMS
AND CONVINCE STUDENTS IMPORTANT
VOTING THAT HEY IT REALIZE THAT
A LOT OF THESE NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENTS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
EXERCISING WHAT VOTING X. IT
REALLY MEANS AND SO WHILE I
REALIZE MY OWN CHALLENGES I
LOOKED AT THERE'S AND I ASKED.
WHAT CAN I DO TO GET YOU TO GET
OUT THERE AND VOTE WHETHER IT'S
FOR ME OR WHETHER IT'S FOR OTHER
CANDIDATES THAT WAS SO MUCH MORE
IMPORTANT FOR ME?
MORE IMPORTANT THAN WINNING.
THE PROCESS WAS SO MUCH MORE IN.
EQUITY IN THE EASY IN THE
EASINESS OF ACCESS TO THE VOTING
TABLES AND IT TURNED OUT --
SPECIFICALLY REMEMBER THE
STUDENTELECTIONS BECAUSE I'VE
MET SOME OF THE MOST INCREDIBLE
STUDENTS AND THEY ARE BEHIND ME
TODAY.
PRESIDENT OF BLACK STUDENT UNION
PRESIDENT OF LGBT Q..
PRESIDENT OF STUDENT GOVERNMENT
THAT HAVE GRADUATED TO ME THIS
PAST MAY BECAUSE OF THESE
ELECTIONS I MET A CREDIBLE
STUDENTS THAT ARE PASSIONATE.
ABOUT VOTING AND THEY HAVE
STRUGGLES TO AND BARRIERS WHEN
THEY VOTED IN THE LAST NOVEMBER
ELECTIONS I'M GONNA TELL YOU MY
STORY I HAVE THREE KIDS I TO
PICK THEM UP FROM CHILD CARE
AFTER SCHOOL.
AND I WAS DRIVING TO THE NEAREST
LIBRARY TO PULLING WELL VOTING --
CENTER.
I COULDN'T FIND PARKING AND AS A
STUDENT SENATOR.
I HAD STUDENTS CALLING MY CELL
PHONE THANK WHERE CAN I GO AND
VOTE.
AND IN THAT INSTANT MOMENT I
THOUGHT WOW.
A NICE TO HAVE THAT AVAILABLE ON
A COLLEGE CAMPUS.
IT JUST MAKES SO MUCH SENSE.
IT'S JUST.
IT'S A NO BRAINER YOU KNOW FOR
ME AS A MOM AS A STUDENT AS A
VETERAN STUDENT VETERANS CALLING
ME AND ASKING ME BECAUSE I HAD
BEEN IN COLLEGE FOR A YEAR -- A
YEAR AND A HALF AT THIS POINT
AND THEY'RE JUST COMING IN AND
OUT OF DEPLOYMENT AND SAYING YOU
KNOW I WANT TO VOTE.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE TO GO I SAW
THE LOOK INTO STUDENT GOVERNMENT
STUDENTS STUDENTS THAT ARE
ACTIVE AND COLLEGE AND WE HAVE A
LOT OF THOSE BELIEVE ME.
PASSIONATE.
AND REALLY BELIEVE IN THIS.
I TO MY MANY MENTORS IN CLOSING
HER NAME IS PAT CARLSON SHE IS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE TOWN AS A
BRANCH OF AMERICAN ASSOCIATION
OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN AND I WAS.
THE PREVIOUS PRESIDENT OF THE A
YOU W. AN EVERGREEN VALLEY
COLLEGE I TELL YOU SHE TOLD ME
THE BEST ADVICE THAT ANYONE
COULD HAVE EVER TOLD ME THAT
I'VE LEARNED [inaudible]
CHAU WHAT.
CAST SHOW UP.
IF YOU SHOW UP YOU WILL SEE
NUMBERS YOU WILL SEE EXCITEMENT
YOU WILL SEE FLURRIES OF
STUDENTS ON THEIR CELL PHONES IN
LINE SAYING HEY THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE AT THIS IS WHERE TO GO.
PARKING EVERYWHERE YOU DON'T
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT.
IF YOU HAVE THAT PASSION BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA LEADS BY EXAMPLE WE
EXCEED STANDARDS IN THE STATE I
BELIEVE THAT THAT'S WHY I CAME
BACK TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE WE'RE FULL OF RESOURCES
FULL OF LEADERS THAT ARE
PASSIONATE.
FULL OF LEADERS THAT ARE HOLDEN
FEARS ABOUT MAKING DECISIONS AB
FIFTY NINE IS A DECISION THAT
SHOULD BE SUPPORTED.
AND HIGHLY RECOMMENDED IF.
SACRAMENTO STATE CAN DO IT.
WE CAN ALL COMMITTEE COLLEGES
SHOULD DO IT I BELIEVE THAT AND
I HOPE THAT MY STORY.
AND THE MODEL LEADERS THAT ARE
BEHIND ME TODAY THAT SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
WILL CONVINCE YOU AS WELL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME
HERE TODAY THANK THANK YOU
THAT'S THE INSPIRATIONAL MY
SENSES THE THREE REPUBLICAN
REPLACE US SOME DAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF SOMEONE TO LONGER BE HAVE A
SECRETARY STAY ALEX BY THE END
NO OFFICIAL POSITION BUT I JUST
WHEN I THINK THE MEMBER WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICE ON ADMIN AND
THINK.
GOOD MORNING SHARON STONE WITH
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
I ANGER IN ACLU OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA'S STATE
IN DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
BUT HOUSING ALL REPRESENTING
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN IN SUPPORT.
I'M SORRY ABOVE YOUNG
INVINCIBLES AND FULL SUPPORT.
HOW THE GROWTH NIXON CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT?
IN A BRAG START WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
A MAJORITY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY.
PHONE SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTY NINE I AM AT THE THOMAS
ALUMNI PRESIDENT OF THE BLACK
STUDENT UNION FOR EVERGREEN
VALLEY COLLEGE IN FULL SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SUMMER SEVERALLY
ALONE I PRESIDENT ASSOCIATES
DESERVE EVERY VALLEY COLLEGE AND
I SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS VAN AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THIS I AM THE
ALUMNI LGBT Q. PRESIDENT OF
EVERGREEN VALLEY COLLEGE.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
BY ROCKO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION COURSE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WE ONLY MET LAST
FRIDAY'S OR SORRY RETURNING WITH
THE LETTER BUT WORDS.
NATIONAL CAMACHO REVEREND DR
RIVER THE CIVIL RIGHTS OUR
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
JEFF HARDY GEAR.
AN ADVOCATE.
INVOLVED WITH THE VOTERS
REGISTRATION AND THE OTHER THING
SO VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT.
SUSAN CARLIN'S.
WITH THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
UNIVERSITY WOMEN HEY YOU W.
SALES A BRANCH WE HAVE OVER
THREE HUNDRED MEMBERS.
WERE IN FULL SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION.
HEY ANYBODY IN THE HOUSE OF
EVERY IN COLLEGE TO THAT.
THIS GUY'S A SHOT.
ARE ALL RIGHT -- BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER CHAIR I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I LOVE IT I
THINK IT'S FANTASTIC YOUR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WERE VERY INSPIRATIONAL I THINK
YOU GUYS SHOULD FIND LOTS OF
BILLS TO SUPPORT AND GO.
AND SPEAK NO SERIOUSLY I MEAN IT
IS SENATOR AMBER CAN TELL YOU WE
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE SUCH
ENTHUSIASTIC AND PASSIONATE
SUPPORT.
AND IT'S CERTAINLY RENEWS MY
REASONING WHY I'M IN THIS JOB SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING THIS BILL AND
EDUCATION.
AND I'LL MOVE IT WHEN THE
APPROPRIATE TIME COM YES AND THE
MEMBERS BE TAKEN EDUCATION
COMMITTEE IS THAT RIGHT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S NEVER MIND.
ALL RIGHT -- WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
BY AS WELL THANK YOU CHAIR
SENATOR -- FOR THE RECORD THE
THE IRAQ GO FOR THE COMMENTS AND
I AGREE THAT -- THE PASSION --
THAT SHOWN BY THESE WITNESSES
ARE JUST -- AN EXAMPLE OF KIND
OF WHAT WE CAN SEE ON CAMPUSES
WHEN VOTING IS SO READILY
AVAILABLE AND I THINK THAT --
BUT THERE'S NO WHILE INDICATED
THE ENERGY THAT'S CREATED AROUND
I THINK CAN REALLY GROW AND SELL
WITH OTHERS TO CAST MY VOTE.
THANK YOU -- AND I HAVE A LIST
OF BILLS TO GIVE YOU SEE YOU
COMBINED.
TO IF YOU LIKE.
ALL RIGHT -- WHEN THE -- WHEN A
QUORUM IS REACHED WILL GO AHEAD
AND TAKE UP THE BILL THANK YOU?
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE NEED BOTH
AUTHORS IN.
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
WILL BE -- IN RECESS IN PLACE
HERE UNTIL WE GET ANOTHER AUTHOR
POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
UNIVERSITIES CAN AND MUST PLAY A
PIVOTAL ROLE IN ENCOURAGING
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
AND INVOLVING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AND OUR YOUNG ADULTS IN OUR
DEMOCRACY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE STUDENT
CIVIC AN AUDITOR EMPOWERMENT ACT.
AND I'M REALLY PROUD AT TO BE
ABLE TO INTRODUCE OUR SUPPORTERS
HERE TO TESTIFY.
DOWN TO LAKE JACKSON FROM THE
AND DOUBLE ACP I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA BEGIN THANK YOU.
I THINK IT'S YEAH OKAY
[inaudible]
SORRY.
I FEEL HORRIBLE FOR A BLOCKING
THE MEMBER [inaudible]
ON OKAY.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOHN LEE
JACKSON AND I'M A FOURTH YEAR AT
CSU FRESNO MAJORING IN
PSYCHOLOGY AND DOUBLE MINORING
IN CRIMINOLOGY AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE.
TODAY I'M HERE REPRESENTING THE
STUDENTS ARE FRESNO STATE.
I'M CURRENTLY THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE FRESNO STATE CHAPTER OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR THE
ADVANCEMENT OF COLORED PEOPLE
ALSO KNOWN AS THE AND DOUBLE ACP.
AS WELL AS THE NATIONAL CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT TRAINER ON FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
AS A MEMBER OF MY CAMPUS AND
DOUBLE ACP WITH THE SUPPORT OF
OUR AND DOUBLE ACP STATE
PRESIDENT ALICE HOFFMAN I
STRONGLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY THREE I AM
GRATEFUL TO BE ONE OF TWENTY
NATIONAL CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
TRAINERS FOR THE AND W. C. P..
PHYSICALLY MY EXPERIENCES IN
THIS ROLE HAVE TAUGHT ME THAT
STUDENTS AT FRESNO STATE ARE
HUNGRY FOR CHANGE.
WITHIN THE CSU SYSTEM ARE
THIRSTY FOR CIVIC SUPPORT AND
EDUCATION.
STUDENTS PURSUING HIGHER
EDUCATION DROUGHT OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION ARE ACHING FOR
GUIDANCE AND A MORE UNIFORM
SYSTEM ARE UNAWARE OF HOW TO
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE.
THIS BILL IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
MY GENERATION HAS NOT BEEN
PROPERLY PREPARED TO COMPETENTLY
AND CONCISELY NAVIGATE OUR GREAT
NATION CIVIC ENGAGEMENT PROCESS
AND THIS IS NO FAULT OF OUR OWN.
WE SPENT FOUR YEARS IN HIGH
SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL AND
GOVERNMENT IS ONLY REQUIRED FOR
ONE SEMESTER.
THIS RESULTED IN A HUGE NUMBER
OF COLLEGE STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF
WHO ENTERS WHO ENTER ADULTHOOD
AN EDUCATED ABOUT CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND CIVIC DUTY.
I'M AWARE OF THE POWER OF OUR
VOICE THE VOTING AND THE
IMPORTANCE INTENDED TANGIBILITY
OF THEIR INVOLVEMENT WITH IN OUR
SOCIO POLITICAL SYSTEMS.
THE STATUS QUO ACADEMIA HAS
STOPPED HAS SHALLOWLY TAUGHT
THAT SUIT AS ALWAYS TAUGHT
STUDENTS ABOUT HOW OUR POLITICAL
SYSTEMS WORK.
BUT NOT ABOUT THE CIVIC WE
ENGAGE VOTERS AND GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZERS WHO MAKE THE SYSTEMS
WORK.
THIS BILL WOULD URGE THOSE WHO
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
IS A DESIGNATED NONPARTISAN
POSITION.
ON THE CAMPUS OF EVERY PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY IN THIS GREAT STATE.
THE HOLDERS OF THIS POSITION
WOULD HAVE THE HONOR AND RESPECT
AND RESPONSIBILITY TO FURTHER
EMPOWER OVER THREE POINT ONE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT MAKE
UP OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
THEIR CIVIC ENGAGEMENT EDUCATION
PROGRAMMING AND RESOURCES.
BY DESIGNATING FUNDS TO A
PROGRAM THAT IS CATERED TO THE
CIVIC RESPONSIBILITY.
WE BELIEVE.
RESPONSIBILITY AND DEVELOPMENT
OF OUR COUNTRY'S NEXT LEADERS IT
IS ONLY A MATTER OF TIME BEFORE
MY GENERATION FLOOD THE JOB
MARKET POLITICAL ARENAS AND
OTHER SECTORS OF OF SOCIETY.
THAT REQUIRES CIVIC WE ENGAGE
CITIZEN WITH A TENDENCY TO VOTE.
AND KNOWING THAT IT IS VITAL
THAT THE LAWMAKERS OF OUR
BEAUTIFUL STATE STATE SET
STANDARDS THAT ENSURE OUR
GENERATION AND THOSE WHO FOLLOW.
ARE ENTHUSIASTIC AND PREPARED TO
COMPLETE THEIR CIVIC DUTY.
AS A PROUD FRESNO STATE BULLDOGS
DUE TO THIS IF CSU SYSTEM AND ON
BEHALF OF THE END OF A C. P..
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO FULLY SUPPORT
AB NINE SIXTY THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JACKSON.
REPRESENTED THANK YOU.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS LIZ
LITTLE CHATTANOOGA I'M IT'S AN
F. AS A STATE AND I AM GOING
INTO MY THIRD YEAR AS A DOUBLE
MAJOR IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
TO KIND OF STUDY.
I CAN ONLY SERVE AS A VICE
PRESIDENT EXTERNAL AFFAIRS FOR A
AS I WHERE I SERVED TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND WITHIN TWENTY ONE
STUDENTS.
I SAY ON SAYS A SAY AS A VOTING
MEMBER WERE NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS ARE BEING
REPRESENTED.
ADDITIONALLY I SERVE AS A
PRESIDENT BY THE DELTA AND
IGNITE.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS ALONGSIDE
OTHERS ALSO SEEK TO EDUCATE THIS
IN A BODY WITH NONPARTISAN
MATERIALS MANY STUDENTS AND TO
GET INVOLVED ON CAMPUS BUT MANY
DO NOT HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
ACCOMMODATE THEM TO BECOME CIVIC
WE ENGAGED.
THIS BILL AIMS TO PUSH FOR AN
EFFORT THAT WOULD EMPOWER A NEW
GENERATION OF VOTERS HOWEVER
SONORA GRADATIONS NOT SUFFICE
THE NEEDS TO GET THE YOUNG
GENERATION TO VOTE.
THIS BILL AB NINE SIX THREE IS A
NONPARTISAN AND HAS A RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED TO GET THE THREE
POINT ONE MILLION STUDENTS
WITHIN PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION.
TO BRING THE POWER TO THE POLLS.
WHEN THE TWENTY FORTY MITTENS
OCCURRED ONLY A POINT 2%
ELIGIBLE EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLD VOTED?
UNIVERSITY STUDENT TURNOUT
INCREASED BY 10% AND TWENTY
FOURTEEN TO TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NATIONWIDE THESE NUMBERS DO NOT
REFLECT THE CONVERSATIONS THAT
STUDENTS HAVE.
IN ORDER TO SEE THE DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLE TO INFECTED WITHIN OUR
COUNTRY THIS BILL MUST PASS
WHERE THE VOICES OF THE THREE
POINT ONE MILLION SINCE
SOMEWHERE -- TING YOU TO LISTEN
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE SECRETARY
OF STATE THE SSA AND THIS AT CSU
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR SIGN M.
O. U. THAT RECOGNIZES.
THEIR SHARED GOAL OF INCREASING
THE DEMOCRATIC ENGAGEMENT AND
CIVIC LITERACY OF STUDENTS BY
WORKING TOGETHER ALL PARTIES CAN
AMPLIFY THE REACH AND STRENGTH
OF THEIR EFFORTS.
ARE WE SO INCIDENT HAVING AN
EVEN GREATER FOR MOIST AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WHEN YOU BILL
I FOR THIS BILL YOU ARE BEING
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THE GOALS OF
EACH OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
AS ALL OF YOU ARE ELECTED PUBLIC
OFFICIALS I MUST EMPHASIZE THE
POINT OF HOW IMPORTANT AND
CRUCIAL OUR ELECTION SYSTEM IS
DISTINCT ALL OF YOU WENT TO THE
HARDSHIP OF SPREADING THE WORD
OF ADVOCATING YOU CONSTITUENTS
TO VOTE.
WITH THIS IN MIND IT IS
UNFORTUNATE TO SEE THAT THE
YOUNGER GENERATION HAS NOT BEEN
A POLITICALLY ACTIVE.
IS THE CENTRAL RIGHT OF OURS HAS
BEEN TAKEN FOR GRANTED AS A
RESULT I'M HERE TODAY ADVOCATING
FOR THE NEEDS THAT YOU AS LIKE
OFFICIALS PASS BILL NINE SIX
THREE WHICH WILL INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF STUDENT BECOMING AWARE.
UNDERSTANDING IN BUILDING DURING
OUR ELECTIONS I CITY BY JAMES
FREEMAN CLARKE A POLITICIAN
THINGS IN THE NEXT ELECTION.
THE STATE'S PERCENT OF THE NEXT
GENERATION SO PLEASE HELP IN A
GENERATION BY PASSING THIS BILL
AS A LIVE TRUCKER ELECTED
OFFICIALS FOR ASSISTANCE AND
GUIDANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YES FRESNO STATE IS
WELL REPRESENTED.
THE BURDEN IS UPON YOU THOUGH
WHAT WE'RE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
AROUND A LOT LONGER THAN WE ARE --
THAT FOLKS ARE RESPONSIBLE
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
HI -- MY NAME IS KIM NALDER I'M
A PROFESSOR OF POLITICAL SCIENCE
AT CSU SACRAMENTO.
AND I ALSO RUN AN ORGANIZATION
CALLED THE PROJECT FOR AN
INFORMED ELECTORATE ON OUR
CAMPUS WHERE WE TRY TO INFORM
VOTERS ABOUT POLITICS AND POLICY
IN A NON PARTISAN WAY.
USING THE TOOLS OF THE ACADEMY
LIKE RESEARCH.
AND SO I WOULD LIKELY BE ONE OF
THE PEOPLE WHO WAS ON THE
COMMITTEE ON MY CAMPUS OF BE
CREATED BY THIS BILL. TWO PUT
FORWARD EVENTS THAT WOULD BE
SUPPORTED BY THIS BILL AND TO
COME UP WITH AN ACTION PLAN FOR
OUR CAMPUS AND AND I DO
ENCOURAGE.
AT A SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL -- I
TEACH THE INTRO TO AMERICAN
POLITICS COURSE THAT ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE EXPECTED TO TAKE
LIKELY BECAUSE THE RED
LEGISLATURE REQUIRES IT
[inaudible]
AND EVERY SEMESTER WHEN I TEACH
THAT I ASK THE STUDENTS HOW MANY
OF THEM GREW UP IN A HOUSEHOLD.
WHERE THEIR PARENTS OR GUARDIANS
TALKED ABOUT POLITICS OR POLICY
OR CITIZENSHIP OR ANY OF THOSE
THINGS?
AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF THEM
DID NOT GROW UP IN SUCH A
HOUSEHOLD.
AND SO THEY WERE NOT SOCIALIZED
INTO CIVIC PARTICIPATION AND SO
IT FALLS ON US AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. TO
FILL THAT GAP IN AND ONE OF OUR
YOU KNOW RESPONSIBILITIES AS
UNIVERSITY FACULTY.
IS TO ENCOURAGE POSITIVE
LIFELONG HABITS AND THE HABIT OF
VOTING IS IS CERTAINLY ONE OF
THOSE.
ANOTHER PART OF THIS BILL I
THINK IS IMPORTANT IS THAT IT
REQUIRES CAMPUSES TO SEND OUT
REMINDERS ON EMAIL AND SOCIAL
MEDIA. FOR REGISTRATION TO VOTE
AND AND REGISTRY AND AND VOTING
BATES AND SO FORTH AND I FIND
THAT TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT TO I
KNOW MY STUDENTS REALLY
APPRECIATE IT WHEN I ENCOURAGE
THEM.
REMIND THEM OF THE DATES OF IN
TERMS OF FINALS AND SO FORTH AND
VOTING IS NO DIFFERENT.
THE UNDERSTANDING OF WHEN THOSE
ARE HAPPENING AND HOW TO
REGISTER AND WHEN TO REGISTER
AND SO ON IS VERY IMPORTANT.
SO I ENCOURAGE VOTING FOR THIS
BILL SO THAT WE CAN KEEP
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE STATE'S
THAT ENCOURAGES VOTING RATHER
THAN DISCOURAGES PUTTING.
THANK YOU PROFESSOR WILL BE FOR
BEFORE WE TAKE MORE SUPPORT
WE'RE GONNA STYLISH A QUORUM.
THE MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU CALL
THE ROLL NUMBER.
YOUR NUMBER HERE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HERE HERTZBERG LEYVA
LEYVA HERE STERN.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
WHICH WAS WITH TRAILER AND
SUPPORT.
SHARON STONE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
I ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SOME OF THE LONG ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX TO THE IN
SUPPORT.
THE ONLY A PRIOR CALIFORNIA
STATE AND DOUBLE ACP IN SUPPORT.
I'M SORRY A YOUNG VEGETABLES
WEST STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
EARLIER.
CHAIR I AGREE THAT YOU WILL BE
HERE LONGER THAN US AND I ALWAYS
JOKE THAT YOU HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF AND SCORING UP
THE WORLD THAT WE HAVE SCREWED
UP.
SO NO PRESSURE -- BUT I AGREE
WE'RE IN GREAT HANDS AND I ALSO
COULDN'T AGREE MORE THERE'S SO
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE WE TALKED TO
THE DIDN'T GROW UP IN A HOUSE.
WE TALKED ABOUT VOTING AND WHAT
NOT AND IT'S JUST SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE MAKE SURE WE ENGAGE OUR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE BECAUSE YOU
REALLY ARE OUR FUTURE.
I THINK YOU SOME LUÍN FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I'LL
MOVE THE BILL WHEN APPROPRIATE.
ALL RIGHT IS THERE NIELSEN NO
QUESTIONS -- ONE OF THE CUT
BETWEEN NORTH YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU ALL SIMPLY I SAY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I'VE.
THANK YOU.
SIR TO THE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS IS A MINUTE TO
SEND APPROPRIATIONS.
NUMBER HI NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN.
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH
.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CERVANTES
[inaudible]
YOU HAVE [inaudible]
A. B..
OF FORTY NINE N. A. B. O. TWO OH
ONE WHICH ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
FIRST.
DO ON MEN -- NUMBER ORDER ALL
RIGHT.
BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY NINE TODAY THE CALIFORNIA
VOTER PROTECTION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN ACTUALLY LIKE
TO BEGAN BY ACCEPTING THE CHAIR
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS.
I WHICH WOULD ALLOW COUNTIES TO
REQUEST A WAIVER FROM THE
SECRETARY STATE TO THE VOTE
CENTER POSITION OF THE BILL.
I IN A REPRESENTED YOU MARKET
SEE LIKE OURS NOTHING IS MORE
FUNDAMENTAL THAN PROTECTING AND
PROMOTING THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
OUR STATE.
HAVE A BODY THIS BY MAKING
VOTING BY MAIL EASIER AND MORE
ACCESSIBLE.
AS A RESULT MORE MORE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS ARE CHOOSING TO EXERCISE
THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE BY MAIL THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MID TERM
ELECTIONS MORE THAN 65% OF
CALIFORNIANS USE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS.
IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT OUR STATE
LAWS REFLECT A GROWING REALITY.
HOWEVER SALLY DURING THE SAME
MID TERMS IT BECAME EVIDENT THAT
THE THESE LAWS ARE ALSO FLAWED
AND WE MUST FIX THEM.
THERE ARE MANY INSTANCES OF
VOTERS WHO DO NOT RECEIVE THEIR
BALLOTS UP UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE
THE ELECTION ON ELECTION DAY AND
SO I'M NEVER RECEIVED THEIR
BALLOT AT ALL.
I REQUIRING THEM TO REQUEST A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
SOME VOTERS AS I MENTIONED I
DIDN'T ARE NOT AWARE OF THE
PROVISIONAL BALLOT PROCESS IT'S
AN EDUCATION HI THAT WE STILL
HAVE TO GET OUT TO THE COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY FIRST TIME VOTERS THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER PROTECTION ACT
WILL HELP FIX THIS IN TWO WAYS
FIRST IT WILL REQUIRE COUNTY
REGISTRARS TO COMPLETE.
THE DISTRIBUTION MAIL BALLOTS TO
EARLY VOTE BY MAIL VOTERS ARE
WITHIN FIVE DAYS WHEN THEY START
THE MAIL.
BALLOT PROCESS WHEN THEY START
MAILING THEM OUT.
I IN THE EXISTING LAW THIS IS
TWENTY NINE DAYS BEFORE THE
ELECTION DAY.
LET ME BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE THE EXISTING TIMELINE
FOR WHEN BALLOT MAIL BALLOTS ARE
SENT.
BY INSURING THAT EARLY
REGISTRANTS ARE CENTER BALLOTS
WITHIN FIVE DAYS OF THE EXISTING
THRESHOLD WILL MAKE IT MORE
LIKELY THAT VOTERS WILL RECEIVE
THEIR BALLOTS ON TIME ALLOWING
THEM TO THE TO DO THE
APPROPRIATE RESEARCH.
ON CANDIDATES AND MEASURES.
COUNTIES WILL STILL BE ABLE TO
SEND VOTERS WHO CHOOSE TO
REGISTER EYES VB AND AFTER THE
EXISTING TWENTY NINE DAYS ON A
ROLLING BASIS.
SECOND THE BILL ALSO REQUIRE
THAT A VOTE CENTER.
I BUT I BOTH CENTER COUNTIES
THAT THERE'S A VOTE CENTER IN
EACH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THAT IS.
FIVE FIFTY THOUSAND POPULATION.
FOR MORE.
AS AMENDED THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
COUNTIES TO REQUEST A WAIVER. TO
THE SECRETARY STATE THAT IT ALSO
EXPLAINS WHY THEY CANNOT COMPLY
WITH THIS REQUIREMENT.
I JUST TO ALSO NOTES I
PERSONALLY HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH THAT THE SECRETARY STAY ON
THIS.
MATTER -- WHICH HE SUPPORTS --
THE FIRST PROVISIONS SECOND
PROVISION THE VOTE CENTERS I WE
DID HAVE A LENGTHY CONVERSATION
IN WHICH WE AGREE TO THIS BILL
GET OUT TODAY WE WILL WORK ON
AMENDMENTS I IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE.
AND SO THAT IS MY COMMITMENT TO
THE SECRETARY I SENATORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
TODAY ON I A. B..
FORTY NINE THANK YOU A WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT -- WE GO.
MELISSA ROMERO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
A MAJORITY WITH A FIFTY LA IF.
IN WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
IF ANY MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
SECRETARY STATE WE ARE TWEENER
AND FIRM THAT THE SECRETARY AND
THE ALSO USE YOUR TWEENER
SEPARATE TWEENER.
WE HAD EXPRESSED CONCERNS IN THE
SECRETARY AND THE AUTHOR OF
SPOKEN AND IF COMMITTED TO WORK
TOGETHER AS NOTED -- TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS OF HOW THIS BILL
IMPACTS THE CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
STRUCTURE OF THE CENTER SO WE
THANK.
HER FOR HER COMMITMENT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORING COMMITTEE STAFF.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISS MOCK
OTHER TWEETERS.
RIGHT ROCKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COURSE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS AGAIN.
VERY MUCH LIKE THE SECTORS
OFFICE.
FINE WITH THE FIRST PART OF THE
BILL WE WOULD LIKE TO STILL TALK
WITH THE AUTHOR ABOUT SOME
AMENDMENTS ON THE SECOND PART
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
QUESTIONS OF BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
BILLS AND MOVED.
YES THERE NIELSEN.
REMEMBER THE THE CONCERNS OF THE
CLERKS -- IS REMAINING OF
CONCERN TO ME AND I CANNOT
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY WE'LL SEE
HOW THE AMENDMENTS GO AS YOU
MOVE AHEAD.
AFTER COULD CONCERNED OF WHAT
THE IMPACT HERE COULD BE ON
RURAL COUNTIES MEET ALL THOSE
CRITERIA I WAS HAPPY TO HEAR
ABOUT THE WAIVER YOU OFFER
DESERVE CONSIDERATION THAT MAY
BE HELPFUL BUT I'M NOT
COMFORTABLE ENOUGH TODAY.
I GUESS SOME OF THANK YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS BILLS BEEN MOVED AHMED
OBSTRUCTED VIEW -- I'M SORRY I
WOULD LIKE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
IF YOU CALL THE ROLL MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER
HI I'M BURKE AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN.
RIGHT WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON
CALL.
NEXT AB.
TWO OH ONE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TO A ONE TWO DAY I AM
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT WE HAVE
COME.
TO AN AGREEMENT WITH THE CLAIM
MANY CAMPAIGN AYE AYES PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED AB TWO OH ONE WILL
REQUIRE CAMPAIGN TEXT MESSAGES
TO INCLUDED DISCLOSURE USING A
HYPERLINK TO THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE.
PLUS LISTING THE TOP TWO FINDERS
HOWEVER IF IT IS UNWORKABLE ARE
IMPRACTICABLE I TO INCLUDE THE
TOP TWO FUNDERS THE COMMITTEE
HAS AN OPTION. TO ONLY INCLUDE
THE HYPERLINK IN THE TEXT
MESSAGE AS A FORM OF DISCLOSURE
I THIS BILL ICE PROPOSED.
I WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT A
COMMITTEE IS NOT LIABLE IF A
RECIPIENT CANNOT OPEN THE
HYPERLINK BECAUSE I THERE ARE
NOT SMART IT'S NOT.
THE NON SMARTPHONE I THE DOES
NOT HAVE INTERNET ACCESS I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND HIS HIS
STAFF FOR ALL OF THEIR WORK AND
THEIR SYSTEMS ON THIS BILL.
I LET ME JUST SIT MOVE BY
TELLING YOU THAT.
I WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT I
MASS CAMPAIGN TAX MESSAGES ARE
THE NEW FRONTIER AS WE NOW WHN
WE SEE EVERY ELECTION OF MODERN
CAMPAIGNING.
I COMPARED TO OTHER FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION THEY ENJOY
INCREDIBLE HIGH VIEWERSHIP AT
THE READ RATE FOR TEXT MESSAGES
IS UPWARDS OF 98% AND UP 290%
WITHIN THREE SECONDS HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED.
I LIKE OTHER FORMS A CAMPAIGN
COMMUNICATION INCLUDING
ADVERTISEMENT OVER TELEVISION OR
RADIO -- OR CAMPAIGN MAILERS
SOME CAMPAIGN TEXT MESSAGES ARE
REGULATED AND MUST INCLUDE
DISCLOSURES ON WHAT ENTITY IS
PAYING FOR THE COMMUNICATION.
HOWEVER DUE TO THE PASSAGE OF
VERY SELECTION REFORM THAT WE
TOOK UP LOST -- SESSION THESE
REGULATIONS OF TEXT MESSAGES ARE
SET TO EXPIRE JANUARY ONE OF
TWENTY TWENTY THIS IS A PROBLEM
THAT HAS BEEN RECOGNIZED BY BOTH
THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
AND THE SENATE ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE PER THEIR ANALYSIS.
I LET ME BE CLEAR NEXT YEAR WILL
BE NO DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS-FOR CAMPAIGN TAX MESSAGES WHICH
IS WHY WE BELIEVE IT IS SO VITAL
TO TAKE THIS BILL UP TODAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO OH ONE WILL
BOTH.
RESTORED THOSE DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AND EXPAND THEM.
IT WILL REQUIRE COMMITTEES OF
ALL TYPES BE A CANDIDATES I BE
IT A POLITICAL PARTY INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURE. TO INCLUDE SOME
FORM OF DISCLOSURE.
TAX MESSAGES ARE YOU A UNIQUE
MEDIUM WHERE THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT IS CONCERNED.
OR ANY OTHER FORM OF MEDIA THE
ABILITY TO EXPERIENCE BOTH THE
POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENT AND
DISCLOSURES BILL INTO THE MEDIUM
ITSELF.
I FOR INSTANCE THE POLITICAL
ADVERTISEMENT ON TELEVISION OR
RADIO YOU CAN HEAR IT YOU CAN
SEE IT AYE AYES IT'S ADVERTISED
BUT YOU'RE ALSO YOU'RE ALSO ABLE
TO READ THE DISCLOSURE.
ON SOCIAL MEDIA THE ABILITY TO
GO ONLINE AND ACCESS SOCIAL
MEDIA ALSO CARRIES ITS ABILITY
TO ACCESS HYPERLINKED
DISCLOSURES THAT EXIST.
THAT THE EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
SPECIAL SOCIAL MEDIA
ADVERTISEMENTS HOWEVER TAX
MESSAGES EXIST IN A VERY GRAY
AREA WHERE THE LACK OF
UNIFORMITY.
AND THE TECHNOLOGICAL CAPACITY
LEADS TO A LACK OF UNIFORMITY IN
THE ABILITY FOR VOTERS TO ACCESS.
FOR AXIS A PAID FOR DISCLOSURE.
INTO A PEW STUDY.
I RELEASED LAST MONTH 50% OF
AMERICAN ADULTS CURRENTLY OWN
THEIR OWN A CELL PHONE DO NOT
HAVE SMARTPHONE CAPABILITIES I
USING TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
POPULATION ESTIMATES THAT MEANS
ABOUT.
THIRTY SEVEN POINT NINE MILLION
AMERICAN ADULTS AND FOUR POINT
FIVE SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ADULTS.
OWN CELL PHONES THAT ARE NOT
SMART PHONES.
THESE AND NON SMARTPHONES USES
TRADITIONAL SMS SYSTEM FOR TEXT
MESSAGES UNDER THAT SYSTEM THE
STANDARD LENGTH OF A TEXT
MESSAGE IS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
CHARACTERS.
BECAUSE OF THIS LACK OF
TECHNOLOGICAL UNIFORMITY IN CELL
PHONES WE MUST BALANCE
TECHNOLOGY ONE NOT INTERFERING
WITH THE COMMITTEE'S ABILITY TO
GET A MESSAGE ACROSS A POLITICAL
MESSAGE ACROSS.
I THIS BILL WE BROUGHT UP IS IS
A VERY REAL CONCERN I WILL SHARE
WITH YOU THAT WE EXPERIENCE IN
THIS LAST ELECTION CYCLE.
I'M AN UNKNOWN ENTITY SENT A
TEXT MESSAGE ATTACKING ME TO
WATCHING ACTS VOTERS IN THE
DISTRICT THAT I REPRESENT.
HOWEVER BECAUSE OF THE CURRENT
STATE OF REGULATIONS ON TEXT
MESSAGES.
THERE WAS NO PAY FOR DISCLOSURE
IT WAS REQUIRED SO NO ONE KNEW
WHO IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
SAID TEXT MESSAGES.
IF WE DO NOT PASS THIS BILL
TODAY WE CAN EXPECT THAT THE
ATTACK MESSAGES PAID FOR BY DARK
MANY MUCH LIKE WHAT I EXPERIENCE
WILL BECOME.
THE RULE RATHER THAN THE
EXCEPTION.
WITH ME.
ACTUALLY I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE BY RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR
YOUR I'D VOTE AND I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS TO WORK
WITH US AS THIS BILL.
HAS BEEN.
RIGHT HERE COMMITTEE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CERVANTES YES.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
MORNING CHAIR AT MEMBERS
FRONTLINE PRESENT A CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN WE WERE IN
OPPOSITION A LESS AMENDED -- WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR.
ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
TO ALLOW US TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION WE'VE ALWAYS
APPRECIATED THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL SHE'S ABSOLUTELY RIGHT TO
DISCLOSE THAT CLEARLY DOES NOT
COVER CURRENTLY.
A TEXT MESSAGES EVEN ROBO TAX --
BY CANDIDATES OR POLITICAL
PARTIES AND SO IT'S ALWAYS
APPRECIATED THE IMPORTANCE OF
THAT PART OF OF THE BILL OUR
CONCERN WAS OF COURSE WE DID NOT
WANT THERE TO BE A A LOOPHOLE IN
CASES WHERE PEOPLE ARE WAS
PRACTICABLE TO SEND THE TOP TWO
FUNDERS BECAUSE EVERY OTHER FORM.
OF ADVERTISEMENT PRACTICALLY
SPEAKING IN THE DISCLOSE ACT
EXCEPT FOR SMALL GRAPHIC ADS.
ARE A MUST SHOW THEIR OF THEIR
TOP TWO FUNDERS -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS THIS A COMPROMISE
ADDRESSES THAT -- TO ENSURE THAT
IN MOST CASES THE DEFAULT IS
THAT YOU SHOW THE TOP TWO
FUNDERS JUST LIKE THE REST THE
DISCLOSE ACT BUT WOULD GIVE THAT
EXCEPTION IF IT'S IMPRACTICABLE
FOR THE SORT THE CASES SHE
OUTLINED SO.
WITH THAT WE WILL -- AS LONG AS
WE CAN WORK OUT THE DETAILS AS I
SOON WE WILL BE ABLE TO AYE
GOING FORWARD -- WE WILL REMOVE
OUR OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMMITTEE FOR HELPING AND WORK
WITH US ON THESE DETAILS AND
THANK YOU FOR PRETTY MUCH TO THE
AUTHOR.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
OTHERS WHO WERE FORMALLY IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF MARK POWERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA BROADCASTERS
ASSOCIATION.
ARE YOUR DISTRICT RADIO AND TV
STATIONS.
WHAT TRêN SAID?
THAT'S FINE OKAY THAT'S X.
EXCELLENT TESTIMONY.
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU OF OF
BOTH THE CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN AS
SOON CERVANTES.
WE WANT TO PEAK TOO EARLY I
APPRECIATE THE YOU'VE COME TO
THIS COMPROMISE LAST TWENTY
MINUTES OR SO.
SO THERE ARE PARENT LEE SOME
DETAILS THAT YET TO BE WORKED
OUT BUT I KNOW YOU ALL WORK IN
GOOD FAITH SO -- OTHERS OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR EYES WAS
A THANK YOU TO BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S A GREAT BILL BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO
REMOVE THE OPPOSITION WHICH
ISN'T ALWAYS EASY SO GOOD
COLLABORATION.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT NUMBER THE BILL WHEN
APPROPRIATE.
THANK YOU I THINK IT'S NIELSEN
QUESTIONS.
I THINK IT'S TIME -- THERE LEYVA
MOVES ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY OF WELL I THINK
YOU'VE CLOSED IT BUT IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN GO AHEAD
SOME LITTLE THANK EVERYONE FOR
EITHER WILLINGNESS AND
COMMITMENT TO WORK ON THIS SIDE
BILL WITH US AS WE FIND THAT.
IT IS MUCH NEEDED AND NECESSARY
TO ADDRESS IT NOW AND AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I ABOUT
THANK YOU.
SIR DID YOU CALL THE ROLL MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER
AYE BURKE AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
I WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU [inaudible]
NEXT THE THE LIVING GLORIA A. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
THE MAN GLORIA WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY EXCELLENT THANK YOU SIR --
GOOD MORNING AND THE PROJECT
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT A. B. --
ELEVEN FIFTY IN MOST CITIES MOST
LARGE CITIES COMMITTEE BECAUSE
DISTRICTS -- CANDIDATES ARE
REQUIRED EITHER PAY A FILING FEE
ARE PRETTY SIGNATURES FOR THE
COMMUNITY THAT THEY WISH TO SEE
THAT THEY WE TAKE FIFTY SIX TO
REPRESENT.
I AFFECT EVERYONE ON THE SERVING
ON THIS COMMITTEE HAD A
CONDITION FOR QUALIFIED FOR THE
STATE SENATE RACE THAT EITHER
POT FILE A FEE OR GATHER
SIGNATURES. FOR THE SAN DIEGO
INCREASE MARKET OF COURSE MCLEAN
MCAFEE BECAUSE DISTRICT BOARDS
THESE SIMPLE REQUIREMENTS DO NOT
EXIST.
AB ELEVEN FIFTY WOULD REQUIRE
CANDIDATES FOR THESE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE DISTRICTS TO COLLECT AT
LEAST A HUNDRED SIGNATURES IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR CANDIDACY.
COLLECTING THE SIGNATURES OF
COMMON SENSE AND DEMOCRATIC
WAITED DEMONT TO DEMONSTRATE
COMMUNITY SUPPORT.
HAVE SOME BACKING IN THE
DISTRICTS FOR WHICH THEY SEEK TO
REPRESENT.
A BEFORE TRADE OVER TO MY
WITNESS I WANNA ACCEPTED
COMMITTEES A MINUTE TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF SIGNATURES -- FROM.
ONE HUNDRED TO FIFTY FOR THE
COMMITTEES EVER QUEST.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SHOULD
HAVE A MOCK UP OF THIS BILL OF
THE FOR ALL OF YOU NEED TO ME
JUST TO ASK WELL I THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO GET SOME CLARIFICATION.
IT WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO START
THAT SOMEONE.
WELL I THOUGHT IT WAS FORTY BUT
IN ANY EVENT I'M SORRY CIVIL.
FORTY FORTY I'M IDEA.
I TAKE IT.
BUT IT WAS IT WAS A GOOD TRY YES --
YES OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OUT BRIAN
HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE'RE
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BELL -- THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE RARE INSTANCES WHERE WE
HAVE BOTH MANAGEMENT AND LABOR
IS SUPPORT OF THE BILL SO THIS
IS A VERY FEEL THE VEIL.
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT THE
MOST QUALIFIED AND COMMITTEE
CANDIDATE WOULD WIN FOR THE
SEATS.
WE STE WE STRONGLY URGE AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE
COMMENTS NONE.
ALL RIGHT BILLS WOULD MOVE.
THE WOMAN GLORIA WOULD LIKE
CLOSE.
FASTER AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
YOU CALL THE ROLL MADAM
SECRETARY MOTION IS TO PASS IS A
MINUTE TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
NUMBER I NUMBER NINE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG.
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN.
NIELSEN.
I TEN KNOW [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN A CERTIFICATE
.
THE SENATORS ARE HERE -- ALLEN
CENTER WIENER.
FLOOR IS YOURS MISTER CHAIR AND
pPLEASED TO BE HERE TODAY -- AND
BOTH TOGETHER MY JOINT AUTHORED
ALSO WITH THE FOR FERMENTABLE
ARRAY OF CO SPONSORS TO PRESENT.
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT.
ONE WHICH WOULD PLACE A MEASURE
ON A FUTURE STATEWIDE BALLOT
ASKING VOTERS TO REPEAL.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
THE PROVISION PASSED BY VOTERS
IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY AND IT REQUIRES
MAJORITY APPROVAL BY VOTERS OF
ANY CITY OR COUNTY FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION --
ACQUISITION OF A PUBLICLY FUNDED.
LOW RENT.
HOUSING PROJECT NOW THE MEASURE
WAS A DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
FEDERAL.
HOUSING ACT OF NINETEEN FORTY
NINE PART OF HARRY TRUMAN'S A
FAIR DEAL WHICH WAS -- THE
INSIDE TO HELP.
LOWER INCOME POSTS WERE FAMILIES
MOVE OUT OF THE SLUMS AND INTO
BETTER LIVING SITUATIONS
[inaudible]
SO.
THOUSANDS IN OUR STATE DID A
LONG LONG TIME AGO BUT THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT.
OUR STATE HAS CHANGED
CONSIDERABLY SINCE.
NINETEEN FIFTY OUR SOCIETY
CERTAINLY HAS VERY DIFFERENT
ATTITUDES NOW ABOUT RACE IN THIS
RACE AND ETHNICITY CLASS AND
POVERTY.
HI BUT NOTHING TO POINT OUT.
WAS AT THE TIME THEY WERE FAR
FUEL TOOLS.
ARE FOR RESIDENTS TO ALTER OR
BLOCK PLANS FOR NEW HOUSING
THERE WAS NO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT THERE WAS NO BROWN
ACT THERE'S NO COASTAL ACT.
THERE WERE FAR FEWER LAWSUITS IN
GENERAL YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
CHARTS ON ON THAT.
SO I THOUGHT NOW ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR REALLY DOES STAND AS AN
ANACHRONISTIC AND EXPENSIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL BARRIER.
THAT SUBJECTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO A WEB OF REGULATIONS AND
COSTLY ELECTIONS A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT END UP DRIVING
UP THE PRICE OF BUILDING
PUBLICLY FINANCED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
AND I WILL SAY IN RECENT YEARS
CALIFORIA'S VOTERS HAVE TIME
AND TIME AGAIN MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT THEY WANT US AS THEIR
pTO DO A BETTER JOB -- BY THOSE
WHO ARE HOMELESS BETTER JOB FOR
THOSE WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO FIND.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
PEOPLE BEEN UP AND DOWN THE
STATE THEY SUPPORTED STATE LOCAL
BALLOT MEASURES TO DEDICATE.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO TACKLING OUR HOUSING
AND OMELESSNESS CRISES.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE REALLY DO OWE
IT TO THESE TAXPAYERS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT THAT ARE AGENCIES
CAN USE THIS MONEY AS COST
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
HI N. RIGHT NOW ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR STANDING IN THE WAY OF THAT.
SO VOTE FOR SCA ONE TODAY.
IT IS IS.
IS IS BASICALLY TO GIVE OUR
VOTERS THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
CONSIDER VOTING TO ELIMINATE AN
OBSTACLE.
I IN THE CURRENTLY IS IN TRYING
TO OUR CONSTITUTION WHICH REALLY
DOES UNDERMINE THE ABILITY OF
OUR ELECTED LEADERSHIP.
IN LOCAL TOWNS AND COMMUNITIES
AND COUNTIES UP AND ON THE STATE
TO ADDRESS -- CALIFORNIA'S ACUTE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
CHALLENGE AND I I REALLY DO HOPE
THAT FOLKS WILL GIVE THIS STRONG
CONSIDERATION.
AND I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR
JOINT AUTHOR HERE CENTER WIENER --
WIENER THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN FOR
COLLABORATING ON THIS I THINK
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
I ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR IS THIS
CAR ON THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION.
FRANKLY IT IS EMBARRASSING.
OUT OF STATE AS PROGRESSIVE AS
CALIFORNIA.
HAS THIS -- THANK THE
DISCRIMINATORY OUR REQUIREMENTS
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT WHATEVER PEOPLE THINK IT
WHATEVER YOU THINK ABOUT WHETHER
HOUSING PROJECTS TO GO ON THE
BALLOT OR KNOCK ON THE BALLOT --
I PERSONALLY AM NOT A FAN OF
PUTTING YOUR HOUSING DECISIONS
ON THE BALLOT BUT EVEN IF YOU
SUPPORT THAT.
ON PARTICLE.
THIRTY FOUR SINGLES OUT ONLY ONE
KIND OF HOUSING HOUSING FOR LOW
INCOME PEOPLE THAT IS PUBLICLY
FINANCED.
AND SAYS THE ONLY BACK KIND OF
HOUSING HAS TO GO ON THE BALLOT
NO OTHER KIND OF HOUSING.
IT IS IRRATIONAL.
I'M PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE DEATH
OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A THREE AND A
HALF MILLION HOME DEFICIT.
AND ABOUT ONE AND A HALF MILLION
OF THOSE HOMES NEED TO BE HOMES
AFFORDABLE TO LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS. TO WE NEED TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO CREATE HOUSING SO THE
LOW INCOME PEOPLE.
REMAIN HAL'S.
AND THIS MAKES IT HARD.
WE HAVE MORE MORE CALIFORNIANS
WHO WERE LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
NOW WE HAVE MULTIPLE BILLS
MOVING THROUGH THE SENATE RIGHT
NOW. TO REQUIRE THE CREATION OF
OF SAFE PARKING PROGRAMS WHILE I
SUPPORT THOSE BILLS -- IT IS A
MORAL FAILURE.
THAT WE ARE IN A POSITION THAT
WE'RE FORCING PEOPLE TO LIVE IN
THEIR CARS.
AND OUR RESPONSE IS LET'S JUST
MAKE SURE WE HAVE SAY PARKING
PROGRAMS WILL THAT'S TRIAGE.
THE SOLUTION IS HOUSING AND AT
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
ONE BY REPEALING.
THE THIS HORRIBLE ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR WILL MAKE IT EASIER TO
BUILD A HOUSING THAT WE NEED TO
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT WE HAVE TO WIN
THIS IS WHAT I WILL POINT OUT BY
THE WAY THAT THE VERY
ORGANIZATION THE CONFERENCE
DECISION REALTORS THAT GOT
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR AND THE
CONSTITUTION THE FIRST PLACE.
IS NOW WHEN VERY PROUD TO SAY A
SPONSOR.
OF THIS.
I SCA ONE WHICH SEEKS TO REPEAL.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR WE HAVE WITH
US TODAY MARK NOT WORN FOR THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND ALSO A LUIS ME THAT
DAY FROM.
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MINES MATTHEW WORN WITH
THE LAW FOUNDATION OF SILICON.
EXCUSE ME THE WEAPONS ARE ALONG
POVERTY THE SPONSORS OF SCA --
ONE BY ALL ACCOUNTS CALIFORNIA'S
HOUSING CRISIS CONTINUES TO
DEEPEN.
IT IS.
BY FAR THE MOST ACUTE FOR THE
LOWEST END.
OF THE INCOME SPECTRUM OUR
CLIENTS.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP THE STATE A
SHORT AN ESTIMATED ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION RENTAL HOMES.
AFFORDABLE TO VERY LOW AND
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ALONE.
OVER 50% OF THE STATE'S VERY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS PAY MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME IN RENT.
AND OVER 75% OF EXTREMELY LOW.
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS PAY MORE THAN
HALF OF THEIR INCOME IN RENT.
GIVEN THE STATISTICS IT SHOULD
BE.
NO SURPRISE TO ANYONE THAT
HOMELESSNESS CONTINUES TO RISE.
TO MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS WE NEED TO
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING
SPECIFICALLY AFFORDABLE TO LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN ALMOST
EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR FLIES
DIRECTLY IN THE FACE OF
ACHIEVING THIS GOAL BY PLACING
AN UNNECESSARY CHALLENGE BEFORE
CITIES IN THE FORM OF A VOTER
APPROVAL REQUIREMENT. TO DEVELOP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THIS REQUIREMENT OF OR LOOK
VOTER APPROVAL HELPS TO
PERPETUATE RACIALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY HOMOGENOUS
COMMUNITIES AND FLIES IN THE
FACE.
OF THE STATE'S LONGSTANDING FAIR
SHARE HOUSING REQUIREMENTS.
AS WELL AS THE OBLIGATIONS ALL
ONE OF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE
UNDER BOTH STATE ANDFEDERAL LAW
TO AFFIRMATIVELY FURTHER FAIR
HOUSING.
MEANING TO TAKE ACTIVE STEPS TO
END SEGREGATION.
AND HOUSING INEQUALITY.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR EFFECTIVELY
ALLOWS COMMUNITIES TO OPENLY
REJECT POOR PEOPLE.
WHO IN CALIFORNIA ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR?
A REQUIREMENT LIKE THIS HAS NO
PLACE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION AND IT'S LONG PAST
TIME THAT IT WAS REPEALED.
I URGE YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU OTHERS.
TERM MMBERS I LOSE MY DAY WITH
CALIFORNIA IN THE COMPANY AND WE
CAN BE WORKS WITH DOZENS OF
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. TO TO PROMOTE PRO
HOUSING POLICY I IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE FOLKS WHO
TRY TO TURN UP TO PLANNING
COMMISSIONS AND SAY YES TO
PROJECTS EXACTLY LIKE THIS.
I WE'RE SUPPORTING SCA ONE TODAY
BECAUSE THE REQUIREMENT TO HOLD
AN ELECTION IS NOT NEUTRAL TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
IT EMPOWERS NIMBY OPPOSITION TO
NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND A
PRESSURES THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
THAT IS BUILT TO BE BILL IN
CALIFORNIA'S BIG CITIES ON
OTHERWISE UNDESIRABLE SITES IN
INDUSTRIAL OR NON RESIDENTIAL
AREAS WE'RE NEIGHBORS ONE OBJECT.
CALPERS FEELING THE DETERRENT
IMPOSED BY ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
SEEK TO SITE HOUSING IN THE
LEAST CONTENTIOUS PLACES BUT
THOSE CAN BE TOXIC UNINHABITED.
AND ARE LIKELY TO FURTHER
CONCENTRATE AND BECAUSE THE
POVERTY THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INTENDS TO ALLEVIATE.
IN ALL THESE EXAMPLES ARTICLE
THIRTY FOUR IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT
COMPLIANCE COSTS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS.
IN UNWISE USE OF LIMITED STATE
FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING.
AT A TIME OF CRISIS CALIFORNIA
CANNOT AFFORD TO SPEND IT SCARES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DOLLARS
OVERCOMING SELF IMPOSED BARRIERS
LIKE THOSE THAT ARTICLE THIRTY
FOUR BILLS.
ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR SHIFTS THE
POWER BOUNCE A POWER TO
NEIGHBORS WHO WOULD SAY NO TO
HELPING LOW INCOME PEOPLE JOIN
OUR COMMUNITY.
AND IT'S TIME FOR THE STATE TO
SHIFT THE BALANCE OF POWER BACK
TO NEIGHBORS WHO SAY YES.
WE STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SCA.
ONE THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
SHAUN BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
BE TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL I'D ALSO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SPEC ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS ALSO PROUD CO SPONSOR
OF THE BILL.
REQUEST YOUR ABOUT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING MALLORY SPOKE OR THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
JULIE SNYDER REPRESENTING
HOUSING CALIFORNIA OUR MEMBERS
CONSTITUTE THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED NONPROFIT
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY.
IN THE NATION AS A SENATOR
MENTIONED ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
ADDS BETWEEN 1-000-028-0000
DOLLARS PER UNIT ACCORDING TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING SO
WE'RE VERY PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE AND ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SHARON STONE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HI DAVID BAY AREA HOUSING
ADVOCACY COALITION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARYLAND SHEA CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HOUSING
AUTHORITIES.
OUR PUBLIC HOUSING THAT
ORIGINALLY.
TARGETED BY ARTICLE THIRTY FOUR
AND THEN SPREAD TO THE REST OF
THE AFFORDABLE COMMUNITY.
SO WITH THAT IT'S WITH PROUD
SUPPORT.
SO WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JULIE CHAPMAN WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO AND WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ELLEN JAMMIN WITH INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IAN HURST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
PATTY BERG WITH HELP OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THIS FEATURE MEMBERS PAT RENTAL
THERE IN READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATON SUPPORT.
ON OUR BEHALF OF THE WESTERN.
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT UP THOSE OPPOSED.
SEEING THE WE DO HAVE ONE
OPPOSED OKAY [inaudible]
MISS BRITAIN.
HI MY NAME IS COLIN BRITAIN I'M
WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA.
OUR ARGUMENT IS VERY SHORT AND
SWEET WE OPPOSE SCA.
ONE WE BELIEVE THAT IT REMOVED
FROM CALIFORNIA'S FROM
CALIFORNIANS THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SELF
DETERMINE.
ANY TERM IN THE CHARACTER OF
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES.
IT NEGATES LOCAL STATUTES DULY
INSTITUTED BY THE VOTE OF THE
PEOPLE AND THEIR REPRESENTATIVES.
IT IMPOSES BUILDING PROJECTS
THAT WOULD A QUINTESSENTIALLY
ALTER THE VERY ESSENCE AND
QUALITY OF COMMUNITY COMMUNITIES
WITHOUT THE SO SCA IS OFFENSIVE
TO ALL THAT IS AMERICAN.
AND AS SUCH IS LIKELY
UNCONSTITUTIONAL I III PC A
STRONGLY OPPOSES SCA ONE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU -- MISS BRITAIN
ALTHOUGH I COULD NOT AGREE.
OUR DISAGREE MORE STRONGLY WITH
YOUR LAST STATEMENT WITH RESPECT --
TO SCA BEING -- ON AMERICAN
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS OTHER QUESTIONS. THIRTY
WAS LIKE CLOSE YEAH I'VE I'VE
DIED THREE SHE THE REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY RANGE OF SUPPORT.
FROM ACROSS THE POLITICAL
SPECTRUM FOR THIS -- SCA I WILL
JUST SAY THAT THAT -- THIS DOES
DOES NOTHING OF THE SORT OF IT
WAS JUST ALLEGE TO IF ANYTHING
IT ACTUALLY.
I IT EMPOWERS THE LOCAL ELECTED
OFFICIALS WHO WERE ALL
ACCOUNTABLE TO IN RESPONSIBLE TO
THOSE LOCAL COMMUNITIES THAT
ELECT THEM. TO MAKE DECISIONS IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE
COMMUNITY.
ABSOLUTELY NO PROJECT COULD BE
IMPOSED UPON A COMMUNITY.
ARE UNDER THIS -- THE ANY
PROJECT THAT THAT WOULD BE
IMPACTED BY THIS WOULD HAVE TO
BE FULLY APPROVED BY THE LOCAL
ELECTED -- WHO ARE ACCOUNTABLE
TO THE LOCAL FOLKS IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES SO I'M?
YEAH YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S A CHANGE
THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN I THINK YOU
SEE THAT REFLECTED IN ALL THE
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE. FOR THIS
SCA TODAY AND RESPECT AS RIVAL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR HELLO MA'AM
SECRETARY.
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED IN RE REFER
TO SENT APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
LEYVA.
LEYVA I'M STERN.
IT WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU AROUND.
I SEE.
LIMóN BERMAN HERE.
AND LET'S LET'S DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- THEM SECRETIVE IS A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THERE LEYVA MOVES CONSENT
CALENDAR CONSENT COUNTER HAS TWO
ITEMS.
AB SIX TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN BERMAN AND AB
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN BONTA.
OKAY NUMBER HI NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
IF THAT OPEN -- ASSEMBLY MEN
[inaudible]
BERMAN.
AB SEVEN THIRTY ITEM NUMBER.
NINE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SANDERS.
AS MORE MORE BAD ACTORS TRY TO
INFLUENCE OUR ELECTIONS WITH
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS THAT SO
CONFUSION AND DOUBT THROUGHOUT
THE ELECTORATE.
I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE WITH
THE PREMISE THAT VOTERS HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW WHEN VIDEO.
AUDIO AND IMAGES THAT THEY'RE
BEING SHOWN HAVE BEEN
MANIPULATED AND DO NOT REPRESENT
REALITY TO TRY TO INFLUENCE
THEIR VOTE IN AN UPCOMING
ELECTION.
THAT IS WHAT MY BILL AB SEVEN
THIRTY IS TRYING TO ADDRESS.
THIS IS ABOUT SAFEGUARDING THE
INTEGRITY OF OUR ELECTIONS.
THIS TASK IS ONLY BECOME MORE
CHALLENGING WITH THE INVENTION
OF PROLIFERATION OF NEW
TECHNOLOGY SUCH AS DEEP FAKES
WHICH ARE EXTREMELY CONVINCING
FABRICATED PHOTOS VIDEO OR AUDIO
RECORDINGS.
OF SOMEONE APPEARING TO SAY OR
DO SOMETHING AND THEY DID NOT
SAY OR DO.
THE ABILITY TO ATTRIBUTE SPEECH
AND CONDUCT TO A CANDIDATE THAT
IS FALSE.
THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
MAKES DEEP FACE A POWERFUL AND
DANGEROUS NEW TOOL IN THE
ARSENAL OF THOSE THAT WANT TO
WAGE MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN RECENTLY THAT
VERY OLD AND CREW TECHNOLOGY CAN
BE USED TO DISTORT REALITY.
THE MANIPULATION OF THE VIDEO OF
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI --
SPEECH WAS ALTERED. TO MAKE IT
SEEM AS THOUGH SHE WAS DRUNK.
WAS VERY LOW QUALITY BUT WAS
STILL VIEWED OVER THREE MILLION
TIMES ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IT IS WIDELY BELIEVED THAT THIS
IS THE NEW FRONTIER IN THE
MISINFORMATION WAR.
THE CARNEGIE ENDOWMENT FOR
INTERNATIONAL PEACE NOTES THAT
DEEP FAKES HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
INCITE VIOLENCE.
CULTURE ELECTION OUTCOMES AND
UNDERMINE DIPLOMACY.
IN JANUARY US DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE DAN COATS
WARNED THAT DEEP FACE WILL
PROBABLY BE AMONG THE TACTICS
USED. TO DISRUPT THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTIONS.
AND IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO THE WASHINGTON POST
IN CENTRAL AFRICA LAST YEAR A
VIDEO OF THE BONES LONG UNSEEN
PRESIDENT ALI BONGO.
WHO WAS BELIEVED IN POOR HEALTH
ARE ALREADY DEAD?
WITH THE CRIED AS A DEEP FAKE BY
HIS POLITICAL OPPONENTS AND
CITED AS THE TRIGGER A WEEK
LATER FOR AN UNSUCCESSFUL COUP
BY THE GOVERNOR HE'S MILITARY.
IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
A BELGIAN SOCIALIST DEMOCRAT
PARTY SHARED A DEEP FAKE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
URGING BELGIUM TO WITHDRAW FROM
THE FROM THE PARIS AGREEMENT.
IN AN EFFORT TO ATTRACT
SIGNATURES FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
RELATED PETITION.
AND JUST LAST MONTH THE US HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES PERMANENT
SELECT COMMITTEE ON INTELLIGENCE
LED BY CONGRESSMAN ADAM SCHIFF.
CAN BE THE HEARING ON THE
NATIONAL SECURITY CHALLENGE OF
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
MANIPULATED MEDIA AND DEEP FAKES.
NOTING THAT DEFACE RAISE
PROFOUND QUESTIONS ABOUT
NATIONAL SECURITY AND DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNANCE WITH INDIVIDUALS AND
VOTERS NO LONGER ABLE TO TRUST
THEIR OWN EYES OR YEARS WHEN
ASSESSING THE AUTHENTICITY OF
WHAT THEY SEE ON THEIR SCREENS.
A YEAR AGO SENATOR MARCO RUBIO
SAID AT THE U. S. INTELLIGENCE
HEARING THAT HE EXPECTED DEFACE
WOULD BE USED IN THE NEXT WAVE
OF ATTACKS.
AGAINST AMERICAN AND WESTERN
DEMOCRACIES.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTIONS
AROUND THE CORNER WE MUST DO
MORE TO CURB THE PROLIFERATION
OF DEEP FAKES AND OTHER
MANIPULATED MEDIA.
AB SEVEN THIRTY WOULD PROHIBIT A
PERSON OR ENTITY WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF AN ELECTION FROM
KNOWINGLY OR RECKLESSLY
RECKLESSLY DISTRIBUTING
DECEPTIVE ALL YOUR VISUAL MEDIA
OF A CANDIDATE WITH THE INTENT
TO INJURE THE CANDIDATES
REPUTATION.
OR TO DECEIVE A VOTER INTO
VOTING FOR OR AGAINST THE
CANDIDATE.
UNLESS THE MEDIA INCLUDES A
DISCLOSURE STATING THAT THE
MEDIA HAS BEEN MANIPULATED.
THE BILL WOULD DEFINE DECEPTIVE
AUDIO OR VISUAL MEDIA TO MEAN AN
IMAGE OR AUDIO OR VIDEO
RECORDING IT THAT HAS BEEN
INTENTIONALLY MANIPULATED IN
SUCH A MANNER.
THAT IT WOULD FALSELY APPEAR TO
A REASONABLE OBSERVER TO BE AN
AUTHENTIC RECORD OF THE ACTUAL
SPEECH OR CONDUCT.
OF A CANDIDATE.
I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT IT IS NOT
MY INTENT TO CAPTURE TOUCH UPS.
SUCH AS DIGITALLY WIDENING A
CANDIDATES TEETH OR CHANGING THE
EXPOSURE.
I'M TRYING TO TARGET DIGITALLY
CREATED IMAGES AND AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDINGS THAT PORTRAY A
CANDIDATE TO HAVE SAID OR ACTED
IN A WAY THAT THEY DID NOT.
I WANT TO THANK THE CHAIRMAN AND
HIS STAFF. FOR THE MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD ON THIS
COMPLICATED BILL.
IF THE BILL PASSES OUT OF THE
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE TODAY.
I WILL AMENDED THE BILL TO ONLY
ALLOW FOR CANDIDATES NOT VOTERS
TO BRING A CIVIL ACTION.
I ALSO WANT TO ADD A LOSER PAYS
PROVISION AND WE'LL DISCUSS THAT
WITH THE NEXT COMMITTEE.
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
TIGHTEN THE LANGUAGE IN
PARTICULAR AROUND THE ISSUE OF
IMAGE MANIPULATION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BILL IS NARROWLY
TAILORED TO JUST ADDRESS THE
MANIPULATION OF THE ACTUAL
SPEECH OR CONDUCT OF A CANDIDATE.
NOT MINOR STATIC TOUCH UPS.
I UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
SIGNIFICANT FIRST AMENDMENT
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS IT IS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED AND I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING THROUGH
THESE ISSUES.
I WOULD NOTE HOWEVER THAT I
HAVEN'T SEEN A COURT DETERMINE
THAT THE FIRST AMENDMENT GRANTS
SOMEONE THE RIGHT TO LITERALLY
PUT IN THEIR WORDS.
INTO MY MOUTH.
WHICH IS WHAT THIS TECHNOLOGY
DOES.
IF PASSED OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY THE BILL WILL BE REFERRED
TO SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
NEXT WHERE I'M SURE THESE ISSUES
WILL GET A THOROUGH VETTING.
HOWEVER AS NOTED IN THE ACLU'S
OPPOSITION LETTER ELECTION
INTEGRITY IS A WEIGHTY
GOVERNMENTAL INTEREST THAT MAY
BE ACCOMPLISHED.
UNDER THE FIRST AMENDMENT IF
NARROWLY TAILORED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
OF OPPOSITION
.
BEFORE YOU TESTIFY I'M GONNA
HAVE TO LEAVE FOR A MOMENT S
SENATOR NIELSEN TO TAKE OVER THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF CHAIR -- AS
THE VICE CHAIR.
OF A COUPLE THINGS ONE I WANT TO
MAKE MENTION -- ASSEMBLYMAN
BERMAN BERMAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH ME IN THE
COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE SOME SOME WAY TO GO --
BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR INTEREST
IN I APPRECIATE YOUR DILIGENCE
SO -- WE'LL SEE THIS AGAIN
JUDICIARY.
AND THE I'LL BE BACK HERE IN.
TWO MINUTES OR SO THANKS THANKS.
I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER.
VICE CHAIRMAN I'M WOULD BE PROUD
THE CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
AND I REALLY WHAT WE SEE IS THAT
WHAT THIS BILL IS CERTAINLY WELL
INTENTIONED WE RECOGNIZE THAT
IT'S ULTIMATELY AN INEFFECTIVE
AND FRANKLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
SOLUTION THAT CAUSES MORE
PROBLEMS THAN IT SOLVES.
THIS BILL IS A CONTENT BASED
REGULATION OF SPEECH AND AS SUCH
IT MUST BE NARROWLY TAILORED TO
SERVE A COMPELLING GOVERNMENTAL
PURPOSE.
AS THE AUTHOR NOTED I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE THAT MAINTAINING
THE INTEGRITY OF ELECTIONS IS A
COMPELLING PURPOSE BUT THE
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
IS NOT NARROWLY TAILORED.
AND IT FEELS THAT TESTED A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT ARE
DISCUSSED IN THE LETTER WE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
ARE ALSO NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
ALL FOCUS HERE JUST ON WHAT I
SEE IS THE MOST NOTABLE LACK OF
NARROW TAILORING IN THIS BILL.
AND KNOCKS ITS LACK OF
EFFECTIVENESS TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM IT'S ATTEMPTING TO SOLVE.
THE BILL RELIES ON A PERSON THAT
SHARING AN AUDIO OR VISUAL WORK
TO DETERMINE IF THE WORK HAS
BEEN MANIPULATED YET BY ITS OWN
TERMS THE BILL ONLY APPLIES WERE
REASONABLE PERSON WOULD BELIEVE.
THE WORK TO BE AUTHENTIC.
HAVING NO RELIABLE WAY TO
DETERMINE AUTHENTICITY THEIR TWO
LIKELY OUTCOMES FROM THIS BILL.
ONE IS I DON'T HAVE A PROFOUND
CHILLING EFFECT ON SPEECH
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE.
I DIS INCENTIVIZE TO SHARE
CONTENT THE PICTURES CANDIDATES
REAL OR FAKE BECAUSE THEY DON'T
KNOW THE DIFFERENCE.
INCLUDING INDIVIDUALS ACTING IN
GOOD FAITH THESE ARE NOT JUST
BAD ACTORS.
THE SECOND IS THAT WE'LL SEE AN
OVER LABELING OF CONTENT
DEPICTING CANDIDATE SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN AVOID LIABILITY UNDER
THE BILL.
THE RESULT IS THAT VOTERS WILL
BE LAST RATHER THAN MORE
INFORMED.
AND EVEN IN CASES WHERE LABELING.
AS MANIPULATED IS APPROPRIATE
UNDER THE BILL.
THAT DOESN'T GIVE THE VOTER
CLEAR INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS WHEN IT COULD BE
SOMETHING AS MINOR AS A TOUCH UP
THOUGH I UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR
INTENDS TO CHANGE THAT.
BUT THIS COVERS A BROAD RANGE OF
WHAT IS CONSIDERED MANIPULATION
AND IT DOESN'T INFORM THE VOTER
AS TO WHAT THE MANIPULATION IS.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT DEEP FIX
OUR AN OLD PROBLEM OF
DISINFORMATION DRESSED UP IN NEW
CLOTHES AND WE ALREADY HAVE
TOOLS TO ADDRESS THAT PROBLEM.
SOLUTION IN TIME WE HAVE MORE
SPEECH AS THE AUTHOR NOTED.
THERE WAS THE NANCY PELOSI VIDEO
THAT WENT AROUND AND WHAT WE SAW
IS THAT THAT WAS SHARED THERE
WAS A CONVERSATION AND IT WAS
CALLED OUT AS FATE [inaudible]
IF.
IT'S NOT CLEAR THAT SOME BEANS
FAKE.
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT EVEN
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION UNLESS
THE DETERMINATION HAS ALREADY
BEEN MADE.
AND SECOND WE HAVE EXISTING
DEFAMATION LAWS THAT PROTECT OR
THE PROVIDE A CAUSE OF ACTION.
FOR A PERSON WHO HAS BEEN WHO'S
HAD THE REPUTATION INJURED AS A
RESULT OF A FALSE STATEMENT
AROUND THEM.
THERE'S A WELL DEVELOPED BODY OF
LAW THAT BRINGS THOSE A
DEFAMATION CAUSE OF ACTION.
IN LINE WITH THE CONSTITUTION
AND I DON'T SEE HOW THAT THOSE
LAWS FALL DOWN IN THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE SO WITH THAT WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE WE WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
GIVE PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME'S MARK POWERS
AGAIN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BROADCASTERS ASSOCIATION THE
RADIO AND TELEVISION STATIONS IN
YOUR DISTRICT.
THERE ARE YOU KNOW THE
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR AUDIENCE
IS BUILT ON TRUST.
BUILT ON TRANSPARENCY TO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
IN OMBATING THESE DEEP FAKE
VIDEOS UP WE HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS
INITIAL EFFORT.
AS YOU KNOW THE WORLD OF
POLITICAL SPEECH IS COMPLEX IS
FRAUGHT WITH PITFALLS AND FOR
THOSE TO TRY TO IMPOSE
RESTRICTIONS.
BASS A REALLY HIGH HURDLE LOCKED.
THIS IS NOT JUST TECHNICALLY
IMPRACTICAL BUT IS LEGALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOUR DISTRICT BOB
BROADCASTERS TO COMPLY WITH.
YOUR SENATE OPPONENT THE NEXT
ELECTION COULD PLACE A DEEP FAKE
AD ON THE RADIO AND TELEVISION
STATION IN YOUR DISTRICT.
HE COULD TELL THE STATION THAT
IS A DEEP BIG VIDEO AND YOUR
LOCAL BROADCAST STATION COULD
STILL DO NOTHING ABOUT IT.
EVEN IF THIS BILL WERE TO PASS.
FEDERAL LAW PROHIBITS RADIO AND
TELEVISION STATIONS FROM
CENSORING A FEDERAL STATE OR
LOCAL CANDIDATES POLITICAL ADS
IN ANY FASHION INCLUDING
DISCLOSURES.
THE ONLY EXCEPTIONS ARE FOR
OBSCENE ADDS AN TO INSERT A
SPONSORSHIP ID.
SO BY PLANT PASSING THIS BILL
YOU PUT YOUR BROADCASTERS IN
EXTREME JEOPARDY.
THEY CANNOT REFUSE A DEEP FAKE
AD NOR CAN THEY PUT ON THE
REQUIRED DISCLOSURE.
THIS BILL ALSO MAKE IT MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE IN DISRUPTING YOUR
LEGITIMATE CAMPAIGN ADVERTISING
BEEN.
BY OTHERS IT'LL HAND POLITICAL
CAMPAIGNS AND ADDITIONAL TACTIC
TO TRY AND FORCE YOUR ADS OFF
THE AIR BY THREATENING
LITIGATION.
IMAGINE YOU HAVE A PICTURE OF
VIDEO AND AUDIO OF YOURSELF OR
YOUR OPPONENT THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO USE IN AND OUT.
YOUR OPPONENTS CAN THEN CLAIM
THE IMAGES OR AUDIO HAS BEEN
MANIPULATED.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO PROVE TO A
MEDIA OUT WHITE OUTLET THAT YOU
DID NOT ALTER?
THOSE IMAGES FOR THAT AUDIO.
BY VOTING FOR THIS BILL YOU'RE
PUTTING YOUR STATIONS IN A
TERRIBLE POSITION.
BROADCASTERS CANNOT PROTECT
THEMSELVES BY REFUSING TO AIR
ADS FOR FEDERAL CANDIDATES.
CAN DECLINE TO RUN ALL ADS FOR
ANY GIVEN STATE OR LOCAL RACE.
ONCE THEY ACCEPT AN AD FROM ONE
CANDIDATE IN A STATE OR LOCAL
REYES.
THEY HAVE TO ACCEPT ADVERTISING
FROM EVERYONE ELSE WITH NO
CENSORSHIP.
SO IF THERE IS NO 1100% ACCURATE
WAY TO DETECT DEEP.
SIX AND BROADCASTERS ARE.
UNABLE LEGALLY TO REFUSE THE
ONES THAT THEY SUSPECT MIGHT BE.
YOUR STATIONS MAY BE FORCED TO
SUSPEND TAKING ANY STATE OR
LOCAL CANDIDATE ADS.
SO WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO MOVE
CAUTIOUSLY AND DELIBERATELY IN
THIS CAMPAIGN AGAINST DEFECTS
BECAUSE AGAIN HAVE GRAVE
REPERCUSSIONS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
YOUR MEMBERS KEVIN BAKER FOR THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS WERE THE OBJECTIVE.
THIS IS A VERY DELICATE AREA.
SPEECH IS AT THE CORE OF THE
FIRST AMENDMENT UNFORTUNATELY
WE'RE NOT CONVINCED THAT THE
BILL IS DRAFT.
THERE YET HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR TO SEE IF
WE CAN GET THERE NOT SURE IF WE
CAN BUT WE WILL TRY [inaudible]
MISTRUST GO.
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS BERNIE
OROZCO THE CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASOCIATION
WE DID NOT POSITIONAL AGO I
APOLOGIZE -- BUT I JUST WANT TO
RAISE SOME CONCERNS ARE VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT MISTER POWERS
HAS SAID LEE TAKENACTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T BLOCKS
RATTLE OR DO ANYTHING TO
ANYONE'S CON.
AND THAT'S THE KEY THING HERE
FOR US -- WE ARE NOT THE POLICE
WE ARE NOT THE CENTER POLICE ON
THE INTERNET ON VIDEO.
OR ON ANY OTHER MEDIA MECHANISM
SO RIGHT NOW THE BILL WOULD PUT
AN OBLIGATION ON US. TO MAKE
SURE THAT ANY CONTENT THAT'S
POSTED IS NOT HAS NOT BEEN
MANIPULATED.
THAT'S NOT OUR ROLE BUT I DO
APOLOGIZE AND WE'RE NOT OPPOSED
TODAY BUT IT ALSO IS REALLY
SOUNDS LIKE IT.
I WILL BE BETTER POSITION FOR
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IT SHOULD
THE BILL MOVE BUT WE ARE GREATLY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
SO MANY CHARGES PASSED LAST YEAR
pANYTHING SO.
THIS IS KIND OF CONTRARY TO THAT
POSITION.
THANK YOU HERE'S WE HAVE ONE
MORE WITNESS.
ERIN RIGHT BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION ALSO APOLOGIZE FOR
OUR LATE -- CONCERNS HAVE NOT WE
DON'T HAVE AN OF SPECIAL
POSITION IN OUR CONCERN IS VERY
NARROW TO THE CIVIL ACTION
PRIORITIES.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
NEARING IT TO JUST THE
CANDIDATES BUT IN REGARDS TO THE
PRIORITY OVER OTHER CIVIL
MATTERS THERE'S MANY STATUTES
THAT STATE THAT THERE MAY NOT
MATTER TAKES PRIORITY. TO TO A
JUDGE WE DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE
ACTUALLY TAKES PRIORITY SO EVEN --
REMOVING THAT PRIORITY LANGUAGE
BECAUSE THEY CAN ALWAYS COME
UNDER AN EX PARTE MOTION CHIARO --
OR ALLOWING THE JUDGE DISCRETION
AND WHEN THEY HAVE TO PRIORITIZE
THESE CASES AT ALL HAVE PRIORITY
SO THANK YOU AND WE LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
UP TO THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS CENTER LEYVA.
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
ALLOWED TO THE AUTHOR I AM I WAS
WONDERING IF YOU COULD ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION.
I THINK THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT BILL AND I THINK IT'S
AN ISSUE THAT'S ONLY GOING TO
GET WORSE BUT I REALLY DO
EMPATHIZE WITH SOME OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE OPPOSITION.
IS THERE A WAY TO GET TO A
NEUTRAL OR A NON OPPOSE POSITION
OR DO YOU THINK YOU GUYS CAN'T
GET THEIR I'M YOU KNOW I'M SORRY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER I ASKED YOU THE
JOB.
SOMETIMES MY HEAD GOES TOO FAST.
THIS COULD BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FIRST THEN WE'LL GO TO YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND LIMITED
SAY AYE AYE.
TOTALLY AGREE THAT THIS IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE AND AND
CURRENTLY NOT A PERFECT BILL --
ANDAND SO WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
GREAT CONVERSATIONS WITH -- THE
DIFFERENT GROUPS THAT ARE OPPOSE
I I THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT ARE EASIER TO WORK OUT THAN
OTHERS -- IT WAS DEFINITELY NOT
OUR INTENT FOR BROADCASTERS TO
PLEASE CONTENT -- AND WE CAN AND
WILL AMEND THE BILL TO CLARIFY
THAT THE OBLIGATION TO ADDED
DISCLOSURES ON THE PERSON
COMMITTEE OR AND TO THE PAYING
FOR THE AD. TO BE BROADCAST --
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
I'M HAPPY TO COMMIT -- TO IN
WERE ALSO -- WORKING WITH THE
JUDGES ASSOCIATION TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE --
I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S
THAT'S EASY TO WORK OUT --
ISSUES AROUND IT CONCERNS ARE ON
THE FIRST AMENDMENT MIGHT BE --
YEAH THERE THERE MIGHT JUST BE.
DISAGREEMENTS AND AND
DIFFERENCES OF OPINION -- ON
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
GONNA DIVE INTO A LOT IF THE
BILL GETS OUT OF ELECTIONS AND
AND GOES INTO JUST THE G.
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND I'M.
RT REACHING OUT TO SOME COM LAW
EXPERTS BECAUSE I HAVEN'T DUSTED
OFF MY CON LAW BOOK IN IN ABOUT
A DECADE AND THE NEED TO NEED TO
REVISIT.
WHAT THE COURTS OF SAID ON FIRST
AMENDMENT -- AND PROHIBITIONS OF
SPEECH THAT ARE ACTUALLY YOUR
SPEECH.
BECAUSE MY BILL DOES NOT
PROHIBIT ANYBODY FROM STATE
SAYING ANYTHING THEY WANT.
TO ABOUT POLITICAL DISCOURSE OR
POLITICAL ISSUES MY BILL THE
SAYS THAT SOMEBODY DOESN'T HAVE
THE RIGHT TO PUT THEIR WORDS IN
MY MOUTH -- NOW I FULLY
UNDERSTAND IT'S MORE COMPLICATED
THAN THAT -- BUT WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP ON WORKING WITH ALL THE
PARTIES INVOLVED TO TRY TO
NEARLY TAYLOR IT -- AND AND MAKE
IT IS PALATABLE FOR EVERYBODY AS
POSSIBLE WHILE STILL ADDRESSING
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT AND AND
DIFFICULT AND DANGEROUS.
TECHNOLOGY BEFORE THE ELECTION
NOT AFTER THE ELECTION BECAUSE
SHAME ON US.
IF WE WAIT UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO DEAL WITH THIS AND HAVE
THE SAME CONVERSATIONS THAT WERE
ALL HAVING IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN VERY GOOD THANK
YOU.
DO YOU THINK WE CAN GET THERE IS
THERE A COMPROMISE SOMEWHERE IN
THIS BECAUSE I DO I DO WORRY
LIKE I SAID BEFORE THAT THESE
DEFECTS ARE ONLY GOING TO GET
WORSE AND PUT ALL OF US IN A BAD
SPOT.
NOT JUST AS ELECTED BUT AS THE
PUBLIC AT LARGE SURE NOT I MEAN
I I'D START BY SAYING WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THE THE
TROUBLING USES THAT THIS
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE PUT TO SO.
I DON'T THINK WE WANT TO SAY
THAT WE DON'T RECOGNIZE THE
CONCERN -- IT'S REALLY ABOUT HOW
WE GET THERE AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE WITH THE ACLU SENATE
BASS WHICH IS WERE ALWAYS HAPPY
TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS.
I HAVE MY DOUBTS AS TO WHETHER
WE CAN GET THERE IN THIS CASE
BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY HAPPY TO
TALK OKAY FAIR ENOUGH YEAH I
THINK THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM
THAT YOU HAVE HERE.
IS THE PROCESS ITSELF.
IF YOU CANNOT TELL.
SOMETHING IS A DEEP ACHE YEAH IF
THE EXPERTS HAVE DIFFICULTY.
HOW CAN YOU PUNISH SOMEBODY
NGUYEN IN THE PROCESS OF YOU'VE
GOT SIXTY DAYS BEFORE ELECTION --
AND NOW LET'S SAY THAT THE
BURDEN DOES FALL ON THE PERSON
WHO CREATED VIDEO TO PUT THE
THING WILL.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA PUT IT ON YOU
KNOW AND SO SOMEBODY COMES TO A
RADIO TELEVISION STATE SOMEBODY
COMES TO A CABLE SOMEBODY COMES
TO A NEWSPAPER.
AND SAYS A THIS IS THIS IS A
DEEP FAKE.
WHAT HAPPENS NOW?
WHO IS THE ARBITER OF OF THAT
FACT AND I'M JUST AFRAID THAT NO
ONE WILL BE ABLE IN THAT ENTIRE
PROCESS? TO STEP IN AND SAY THIS
IS A DEEP FAKE THIS IS NOT A
DEFECT RIGHT AND SO HOW CAN WE
POLICE IT GIVEN THAT.
VERY FAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU
LOOK LIKE YOU WANT TO RESPOND
YEAH YEAH I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND --
THE CONCERNS THAT ARE BEING
REYES AND THEY JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT DARPA THE DEFENSE ADVANCED
RESEARCH PROJECTS AGENCY OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LAUNCHED A
MEDIA FORENSICS PROGRAM A COUPLE
YEARS AGO IN -- TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN THAT SPONSOR RESEARCH TO
TO TRY TO FIGURE THIS OUT HOW DO
I DO WE IDENTIFY.
DEEP FAKES -- AND UC BERKELEY
PROFESSOR AN IMAGE FORENSICS
EXPERT HONEY FOR READ AND I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT BUT SHOULD THE
PRONUNCIATION -- AND HIS
COLLEAGUES ARE CURRENTLY
DEEP FACE OF PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES -- PRIOR TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION IN
ADDITION A WELL KNOWN POLITICAL
FIGURES SUCH AS DONALD TRUMP
THERESA MAY JUSTIN TRUDEAU AND
OTHERS SO I I THINK YOU KNOW THE
FOLKS ARE WORKING ON THE
TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
IDENTIFIED I THINK IT'S ONCE.
WE KNOW THAT SOMETHING IS A DEEP
FAKING THAT WE CALL IT A DEEP
FAKE WHICH I WOULD ARGUE IS
USING MORE SPEECH.
THE COMBAT FALL SPEECH -- YOU
KNOW WE ACTUALLY IDENTIFY FOR
THE PUBLIC HEY THIS IS FAKE --
IS IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
AT AND I THINK IT JUST DEPENDS
ON WHO THAT BURDEN FALLS ON IN
THE PROCESS TO TURN I HEAR
EXACTLY TRISTAN I GOTCHA THANK
YOU.
I'M GONNA SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BECAUSE I DO THINK THIS IS A
VERY SERIOUS ISSUE I HOPE THAT
WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER --
SO THANK THANKS TO EVERYONE --
AND I'M OF THE BILL
INAPPROPRIATE.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE
A CLOSER SEMBLANCE.
THANK YOU FOR THE CONVERSATION.
I KNOW THAT THIS IS COMPLICATED
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE FOLKS
OUT OF ENGAGED -- WE KNOW THAT --
YOU GUYS AS WE KNOW IS
LEGISLATORS WE ONLY KNOW SO MUCH
UNTIL WE PUT SOMETHING IN PRINT
AND WE GET FEEDBACK FROM OTHERS --
AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE GOTTEN AND
DEFINITELY WANT TO TRY TO WORK
OUT -- AS MANY ISSUES AS
POSSIBLE.
RESPECTED AS FOR AYE VOTE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THIS WILL GO
BACK TO RULES AND THEN LIKE
COULD BE REFERRED TO JEWS
JUDICIAL THERE WILL BE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY -- AND IF YOU HAVE
GOTTEN YOUR MOTION DO PASS I
WOULD HAVE GIVEN YOU A COURTESY
ONE EVEN THOUGH I'M NOT READY TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY BUT YOU HAVE
YOUR MOTION SO LET US GO AHEAD
TO THE ROLL CALL.
AND THIS WOULD BE TO RECOUP
REFER TO RULES AND THEN TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO NIELSEN NOW HERTZBERG LEYVA
LEYVA AYE.
THEM KEEP THE ROLE OPEN ON HOLD
AND GOOD LUCK TO YOU SIR THE
USER [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE MULLIN.
THE DAY SIR YOU BRING IS AB.
FIVE SEVEN ONE THANK YOUSIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR MEMBERS
PRESENTING AB.
FIVE SEVEN ONE CALIFORNIA.
IS ONE OF THE VERY FEW STATES TO
HAVE STATE CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS.
BUT NOPE OPAL CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT
UNLESS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ADOPTED SOME CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
LITERALLY ANY AMOUNT CAN BE
CONTRIBUTED DIRECTLY TO A
CANDIDATE FOR LOCAL OFFICE.
WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES OF CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS RECEIVING DIRECT
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A SINGLE
DONOR.
THAT ARE HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
CALIFORNIANS ANNUAL SALARY EVEN
SINGLE CAN CONTRIBUTIONS AS HIGH
AS ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
CONTRIBUTIONS OF THIS MAGNITUDE.
UNDERMINE PUBLIC TRUST IN
DEMOCRACY THIS BILL CREATES A
REASONABLE DEFAULT CONTRIBUTION
LIMIT TO STOP EXCESSIVE CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR CITY AND
COUNTY RACES WHILE ALSO
RESPECTING LOCAL CONTROL.
AB FIVE SEVEN ONE ESTABLISHES
DEFAULT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS OF FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES THAT HAVE
NOT ADOPTED THEIR OWN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
THIS IS THE EXACT SAME AMOUNT AS
THE STATE INDIVIDUAL
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS WE ARE BOUND
BY IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE.
IT IS IMPORTANT STRESS THAT AB
FIVE SEVEN ONE MAINTAINS
COMPLETE LOCAL CONTROL AT ANY
POINT EVEN TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW.
A LOCAL JURISDICTION CAN OPT OUT
BY ENACTING ITS OWN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS WHETHER LOWER OR HIGHER
THAN THE DEFAULT.
WITH ME TODAY IS NICOLAS HIRED
ON WITH CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
INDOOR ROSE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS TO OFFER ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR NICHOLAS
HAD ON REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB.
FIVE SEVEN ONE WE BELIEVE WILL
HELP SECURE THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA CITY AND COUNTY
ELECTIONS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE DEFAULT IS
THAT THERE ARE NO CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MAY
NOT CONTRIBUTIONS.
LIMITS IF THEY WISH THIS BILL
MERELY SHIFTS THAT PRESUMPTIONS
OF THE DEFAULT IS THAT THERE ARE
LOCAL CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS LIMITED TO FORTY SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS THE SAME AS THE
STATE.
IT WOULD INCREASE INFLATION
ALONG WITH STATE LIMITS BUT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CRUCIALLY
STILL RETAIN THE POWER TO ENACT
THEIR OWN LIMITS WITH THE BE
LOWER OR EVEN HIGHER.
THAN THAT DEFAULT.
ONLY THE VAST MAJORITY OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CALIFORNIA HAVE NO
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS -- IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
DID A STUDY FINDING ABOUT A
QUARTER CITIES AND COUNTIES.
HAVE ADOPTED CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
IS DESPITE THE FACT THAT THE
VOTERS HAVE AT LEAST TWICE VOTED
TO ESTABLISH STATE AND LOCAL
LIMITS.
IT'S SIMPLY QUIRK OF HISTORY
THAT THOSE LIMITS WHICH WERE --
LITIGATED ON THE STATE BASIS
MORE HOLD THE COURTS AND THE
FINAL INITIATIVES CREATE OUR
STATE LIMITS ONLY DID STAY
LIMITED THROUGH THE QUIRK OF
HISTORY THAT WE'VE ENDED UP WITH
NO CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
UNLIMITED DONATIONS -- COMMON
CAUSE FIRMLY BELIEVES AS A
PROBLEM FOR DEMOCRACY THEY OPEN
THE DOOR TO CORRUPTION AND PLAY.
CREATE THE PARENTS OF SPECIAL
INTERESTS CONTROL WHICH MORE
LIES OUR DEMOCRACY AND HELPING
COMMENTS AND TRANSOM SELVES
AGAINST COMPETITION.
I AB FIVE SOMEONE DRESSES THIS
PROBLEM INHERENT WAS SYSTEM
UNLIMITED CONTRIBUTION LIMITS BY
CREATING JUST A REASONABLE FORTY
SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR DEFAULT CAP.
IN CLOSING JUST ONE MENTION
CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF ONLY FOUR
STATES HAVE STATE CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS BUT NO LOCAL LIMITS WE
SHOULD NOT BE NO WIRE WHEN IT
COMES SAFEGUARDING INTEGRITY FOR
LOCAL ELECTIONS FOR THIS REASON
WE STRONGLY URGE WHEN I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU.
COMMENTING CENTER NIELSEN THOROS
LEGAL RIVERS A CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY.
THE LEAGUE WORKS EVERY DAY TO
BUILD VOTER ENGAGEMENT AND THE
PUBLIC'S CONFIDENCE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS TO COMBAT.
THE CYNICISM THAT'S CAUSED BY
THE PERCEPTION AND SOMETIMES THE
REALITY OF POLITICIANS.
OF WHO MIGHT PUT THE INTERESTS
OF THE DONOR CLASS AHEAD OF THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
MONEY PRESENTS ONE OF THE
GREATEST THREATS TO
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY TODAY
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT DISTORTS
INCENTIVES.
RIGHT.
IT'S THE MAKES THE COMPETITION
IN EQUITABLE.
AND IT DROWNS OUT THE VOICES OF
ORDINARY VOTERS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND COUNTIES AS YOU'VE HEARD
HAVE NO -- CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS AT ALL AS A RESULT LOCAL
CONTRIBUTIONS ARE LARGER SO THE
ONES THAT STAYED ELECTIVES ARE
PERMITTED TO HAVE.
AT TIMES LOCAL CANDIDATES RELY
ON JUST A FEW LARGE DONORS TO
FUND THEIR CAMPAIGN ONE OR TWO
WHEN THEIR ENTIRE CAMPAIGN.
IT MAKES SENSE TO ESTABLISH THIS
REALISTIC DEFAULT LIMIT ON LOCAL
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS SAID AT
THE SAME LEVEL.
AS LEGISLATIVE CAMPAIGNS HAVE
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE ADOPTED
THEIR OWN AT LOCAL CONTRIBUTION
LIVE LIMITS AS YOU'VE HEARD
WOULDN'T BE IMPACTED BY THE BILL
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WOULD REMAIN
FREE TO SET A HIGHER OR LOWER
LIMIT AS THEY DESIRE -- SO WHAT
WE BELIEVE THAT AB. FIVE SEVENTY
ONE CURVES THE INFLUENCE OF
MONEY IN POLITICS AND IT'S
STRENGTHENS REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY WHILE SIMULTANEOUSLY.
PRESERVING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FLEXIBILITY TO SET LIMITS TO
SUIT THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES NEEDS SO WE
URGE ITS PASSAGE THANK YOU.
RIGHT.
ANOTHER WITNESS HERE.
MELISSA ROMERO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
TRAVELING WITH CALVIN CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. TO THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE.
CENTER LEYVA ASSEMBLYMAN MALONE
HAS JUST COMPLETED AND WE'VE HAD
THE TESTIMONY FOR WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION THAT HAS COME FORTH.
A DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THIS POINT.
AT THE EXPLAINED TO ME NOW HOW
THE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
EXCEED THE FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
HOW WOULD THEY DO THAT.
BILL.
SENATOR THEY COULD SIMPLY ADOPT
AN ORDINANCE TO THAT EFFECT AND
SET A HIGHER LIMIT OR A LOWER
LIMIT IT'S UP.
A COMPLETELY UP TO THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THIS IS SIMPLY A
DEFAULT WHERE THERE'S WITH THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAS NOT PUT IN
OR IN SOME PLACE.
THAT A FORTY SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR LIMIT WOULD WOULD BE
APPLICABLE.
OKAY.
I WANTED TO HAVE THAT CLARIFIED.
ALL RIGHT THAT SAID THEN WE HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMITTEE WE
HAVE NONE WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE WILL CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE BILL -- CLOSING OF COURSE
I'M SORRY OF RESPECT FASHIONABLE
OF COURSE [inaudible]
WHAT?
MOTION IS TO PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
NIELSEN RATING [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
A SEVEN I'M SORRY WE'RE VERY
SHORT OF COMMITTEE BUT THEY WILL
ALL GET HERE AND WE'LL PUT THE
BILL ON HOLD -- ON HOLD AND YOU
WILL BE ABLE TO GET YOUR VOTE.
GO AHEAD PLEASE.
A MISTER REISS HEREBY PRESENTING
A. B..
EIGHT SIXTY FOUR NEXT THIS IS
OUR DISCLOSE ACT CLEANUP
LEGISLATION.
CAMPAIGN SPENDING ON BALLOT
MEASURES HAS REACHED
UNPRECEDENTED LEVELS OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS HAS BEEN SPENT
IN CALIFORNIA AND BALLOT MEASURE
ADD SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT
TRY TO HIDE THE TRUE IDENTITIES
OF TOP DONORS OFTEN EMPLOYING
MISLEADING NAMES.
ARE BY MAKING THEM DIFFICULT TO
READ.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
MORE WAS SPENT ON INDEPENDENT
EXPENDITURES SUPPORTING OR
ATTACKING CANDIDATES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN I AUTHORED AB TWO FOUR
NINE THE DISCLOSE ACT WHICH
ALLOWED VOTERS TO MORE EASILY
SEE THE TOP FUNDERS A BALLOT
MEASURE.
AND INDEPENDENT EXPENDITURE ADS
TELEVISION ADS ARE NOW REQUIRED
TO SHOW DISCLOSURES FOR FIVE
SECONDS LISTING THE TOP THREE
FUNDERS OF THE AD AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT LAST YEAR EXTENDED
DISCLOSURE REQUIREMENTS TO
ONLINE SOCIAL MEDIA.
POLITICAL ADVERTISING SINCE THE
PASSAGE OF THOSE TWO BILLS THE
F. PPC RACING NUMBER SMALL
ISSUES THAT NEEDED FURTHER
CLARIFICATION.
AND AB EIGHT SIX FOUR SIX TO
ADDRESS THOSE MINOR CONCERNS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
A TREND L<c.cyan>G EXECUTIVE THE</c>
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
WE WERE -- PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
TWO FORTY NINE AND AND WORK WITH
THE SPEAKER PRO TEM MULLIN ON
THAT.
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SOCIAL MEDIA DISCLOSE ACT --
THIS BILL DOES HAVE SOME --
VALUABLE CLARIFICATIONS
REQUESTED BY THE F. PPC THAT WE
THINK MAKE MAKE SENSOR STIMPSON
BONE STRAIGHTFORWARD SO.
WE THINK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRING IT FORWARD IN.
RESPECTED REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE ANYTHING SIR.
NOW COME.
FOR A SHARON STONE THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
WILLOWS MOOD I HAVE NO QUESTIONS
ASKED NO QUESTIONS.
HE WAS TO HAVE A CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR LEVEL
THANKS SIR.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE NUMBER.
NIELSEN ANY.
NIELSEN ABSTAINING HERTZBERG
LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE STERN.
AGAIN WE'LL HAVE SOME TIME TO
GET MEMBERS BACK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN.
WELL THE AUTHORS AND MEMBERS
.
AB [inaudible]
TWO TWENTY YES.
MORNING IF YOU'RE READY.
MORNING MR CHECK WARNING
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWO TWENTY TODAY.
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL WHICH
REMOVES BARRIERS TO ANYONE
SEEKING TO SERVE IN ELECTED
OFFICE BY ALLOWING.
EVERY CANDIDATE.
THE USER CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR
CHILDCARE EXPENSES INCURRED AS A
RESULT OF CAMPAIGNING THIS BILL
WILL HELP PARENTS WITH YOUNG
CHILDREN SERVE IN PUBLIC OFFICE.
IT WILL ALSO HELP TO ADVANCE
MUCH NEEDED GENDER PARITY AMONG
OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS CURRENTLY
WOMEN COMPRISED TWENTY OR 30% OF
THE LEGISLATURE BATS EXACT
THAT'S ACTUALLY GROWTH.
OVER LAST SESSIONS TOTAL OF 22%
BUT IT'S CLEAR THAT THESE
NUMBERS STILL FALL FAR SHORT.
OF GENDER PARITY YOUNG PARENTS
BRING IMPORTANT VOICES THE
POLICY DEBATES USER VOICES WE
NEED TO HEAR MORE OF NOT LESS.
ANYONE WHO CURRENTLY TRIES TO
USE CAMPAIGN FUNDS FOR CHILDCARE
FACES RISK.
AND UNCERTAINTY THEY WOULD BE
RELYING ON A TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD INFORMAL ADVICE LETTER BY
THE F. B. B. C. THIS BILL OFFER
EVERYONE WHO WANTS TO SEE
CONSERVE A PUBLIC OFFICE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CAMPAIGN.
WITHOUT HAVING TO WORRY ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WILL RUN AFOUL OF
OUR STATE COMPLICATED AND IN
THIS REGARD.
UNCERTAIN CAMPAIGN FINANCE LAWS.
RECENT AMENDMENT SPECIFY THESE
FUNDS CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
CAMPAIGN RELATED EXPENSES THAT
WOULD NOT NORMALLY BE INCURRED.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS THE F. B.
B. C. HAS MOVED FROM A SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION TO A FULL
SUPPORT POSITION.
THIS BIPARTISAN BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IT HAS --
IT'S ALSO SUPPORTED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN THIS COMMITTEE AND HERE WITH
ME TO TESTIFY ON A. B. TWO
TWENTY IS AMBER MALTBY SHE'S A
PARTNER.
AT NASIM IN L. L. P.
SPECIALIZING IN CAMPAIGN FINANCE
LAW AND SHE'S THE IMMEDIATE PAST
CHAIR.
OF EMERGE CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU AND AND GOOD MORNING
SENATORS AND AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE AND THANK YOU I'M
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE -- AS A
MATTER AS A MEMBER BY DECIDE MY
NAME IS AMBER MALL TO BE I'M A
PARTNER AT THE LAW FIRM NAS MEN --
WHERE THAT PRACTICE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE AND ELECTION LAW ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY FOR THE LAST TEN
YEARS AND FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS OF MY LIFE I'VE BEEN?
I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR ELECTING
MORE WOMEN INTO OFFICE AND WOMEN
OF COLOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
GENERALLY -- I AM HERE TODAY AND
NOT -- ON BEHALF OF A PARTICULAR
CLIENT BUT RATHER TO SPEAK TO
YOU ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE -- WITH
THE INTERSECTION BETWEEN
CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND BEING A
GENDER EQUALITY ADVOCATE.
AND I'M THERE ARE TWO THINGS
THAT THAT I'VE SEEN -- ONE OVER
THE LAST TWENTY OR SO YEARS I'VE
EITHER TRAINED OR COUNSELED YEAR
WELL OVER A HUNDRED WOMEN
CANDIDATES -- ONE OF THE MAIN
ISSUES OUT WOMEN DECLINED TO RUN
OR WAIT UNTIL LATER IN THEIR
LIFE TO RUN S BECAUSE OF HOME
AND HOUSEHOLD RESPONSIBILITIES --
THE ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWO TWENTY
WOULD ALLOW WOMEN AND ALL
PARENTS OF YOUNG CHILDREN -- TO
BE ABLE TO RUN FOR OFFICE SOONER
THAN THEY MIGHT.
OTHERWISE IT TOO SO.
I'M ALSO AB TWO TWENTY CLARIFY
IS A LONGSTANDING OF PPC ADVICE
AND I WANT TO PUT INTO CONTEXT
WHAT THAT THE ADVICE LETTER THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA THAT
MENTIONED.
I'M THE FAIR POLITICAL PRACTICES
COMMISSION WHICH REGULATES
CAMPAIGN FINANCE CAN ISSUE AND I
BY SWEATERS TO ANYBODY WHO ASKS
FOR THEM.
THESE ARE HELPFUL THEY ARE NOT
PRESIDENTIAL.
SO WHAT THAT MEANS IS ANY
CANDIDATE WHO LATER RELIES ON
THE LETTER.
COULD BE PROSECUTED BY A
COMMISSION COMPRISED OF OF
DIFFERENT COMMISSIONERS --
DIFFERENT -- LEGAL COUNSEL
ETCETERA -- AND ISRAEL THIS
SHOULD NOT ONLY PROVIDES CLARITY
FOR THE REGULATED COMMUNITY
THERE'S ALSO PROVIDES NEEDED
CLARITY TO THE F. PPC.
SO THEY KNOW -- YOU KNOW IT THAT
THEY'RE NOT GUESSING THE
BOUNDARIES OF WHETHER OR NOT
CAMPAIGN FUNDS CAN BE USED.
FOR CHILD CARE -- I WILL ALSO
JUST ADD AB TWO TWENTY IS
INCONSISTENT WITH -- THAT THE
CURRENT TREND ACROSS THE STATE
LEGISLATURES AND CAMPAIGN
FINANCE REGULATORY BODIES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA -- AT AS
OF TODAY AT LEAST TWELVE STATES
HAVE APPROVED USING CAMPAIGN
FUNDS FOR CHILD CARE IN ADDITION
TO THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMISSION -- EITHER THROUGH
LEGISLATION OR THROUGH ADVISORY
OPINIONS AND FOR THOSE FOR USE
THAT REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT AB.
TWO TWENTY IF SOMEONE THE ONE ON
THE HAVE A SECRETARY STATE ALEX
BUT THE AND SUPPORT.
MR TURNED SENATORS MADISON
DAHLIA BEHALF OF ALAMEDA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
MR TURN MEMBERS SILVIUS ALICIA
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT.
I CAN'T THE QUESTIONS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THE QUESTION IS THE COMMENT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND CODIFYING A PRACTICE
SO THAT IT IS NOW LAW OR
HOPEFULLY BE LAW -- BECAUSE THE
MORE WE CAN DO TO GET WOMEN INTO
OFFICE AS YOU NOTED -- IS SO
IMPORTANT WE'RE AT 30% BUT WE
NEED AT LEAST TO BE A 50%.
ALSO GOT A WAYS TO GO AND I'M
SURE THIS WILL HELP AS YOU
STATED TO BRING -- PARENTS
MOTHERS ESPECIALLY WHO MIGHT NOT
HAVE COME AND RUN FOR OFFICE
EARLIER BECAUSE OF CHILD CARE
THIS MIGHT GET IN THERE SO THANK
YOU AND I'M OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA -- AND I
NOTICED THE TESTIMONY WAS
FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON WOMEN --
INSTANCE I SEE NO OTHER AUTHORS
PRESENT I'LL GO AHEAD AND TELL
MY WAR STORY.
SO THREE WARS AGO THE DAY I WAS
FIRST WORN TO THE ASSEMBLY.
MY WIFE WAS ACTIVE IN OPERATION
DESERT STORM AND WAS GONE FOR
SEVEN MONTHS LEAVING ME HOME
WITH THE SEVEN FOUR IN TWO YEAR
OLD -- AND SO ONE OF THE GREAT
CHALLENGES IN LIFE AT THE TIME
WAS BEING IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
A TARGETED SEE BY THE WAY.
AND ALSO.
BEING RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT SEVEN
FOUR AND TWO YEAR OLD IT WAS A
IT WAS A CHALLENGING TIME MY
SEVEN YEAR OLD STILL TALKS ABOUT
IT IN MY FACE TO BE ABLE TO
BRAID HAIRED DO ALL KINDS OF
OTHER THINGS -- BUT I WAS
BECAUSE I WAS IN A TARGET SEAT
WAS STILL CAMPAIGNING AND WE
WERE IN A VERY CHALLENGING
SITUATION SO IN ADDITION.
TO WOMEN I THINK THIS ALSO
BENEFITS -- MEN WHO ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE IT'S OR OR EITHER
PARENT WHO IS IN A POSITION WHO
WHO MAY NOT BE ABLE TO RUN FOR
OFFICE BECAUSE THEY LACK FOR
CHILD CARE IN THEIR FIRST
RESPONSIBILITY BEING THEIR
FAMILY -- MAY END UP FOR GOING
AT HISTORICALLY BUT THIS BILL
HELPS WITH THAT SITUATION SO I
CONGRATULATE YOU -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THE ONE
INCORPORATE MINE.
SO I WILL EASE YOUR M. CREDIBLE
STATEMENT MISTER CHAIR OF THE
CLOTHES AND RESPECT THE ASPEN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU --
AB SECTORS ARE MOTION.
THE OKAY.
MOST AGREE CULTURAL MOTION IS TO
PASS TO SENATE APPROPRIATE
EXCUSE ME.
MOTION IS DO PASS.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL KEEP
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
STAFF.
ICE YES.
ALL RIGHT.
I SEE A ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GIPSON HERE DON'T TAKE THAT
PERSONALLY SEVEN MEMBER GIPSON.
THAT CENTER LEYVA SOCIAL BE BACK
SO.
WE HAVE LEFT -- SO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON AB
[inaudible]
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN YES SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU
ALLOW ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN WHICH
WOULD HELP PROVIDE INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN COUNTY JAILS
INFORMATION.
ON VOTER REGISTRATION AND VOTING
RIGHTS CALIFORNIAN CARS RATES
OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
IN IS JAILS AND MORE THAN HALF
OF THEM HAVE NOT BEEN CONVICTED
OR ARE ON SENTENCE.
THIS IS A LARGE COMMUNITY THAT
HAS EXTORT CLING BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM CIVIC PARTICIPATION DUE TO
EITHER MISS INFORMATION OR A
LACK OF INFORMATION.
MANY.
WHO ARE BEHIND BARS DO NOT KNOW
THAT THEY CAN REGISTER TO VOTE?
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES STATE AND
LOCAL -- JUVENILE DETENTION
FACILITIES TO ASSIST IN BORDER
REGISTRATION FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE OF AGE AND ARE NOT SERVING
AND I WANT TO UNDERSCORE NOT
SERVING A FELONY -- CENTERS THIS
BILL WILL.
IN ACTS SIMILAR PROVISIONS FOR
ADULTS BY REQUIRING EACH COUNTY
JAIL TO ALLOW AT LEAST.
ONE ORGANIZATION AT LEAST ONE
ORGANIZATION TO PROVIDE A VOTER
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE COUNTY
JAILS THE PROGRAM WOULD INCLUDE
INFORMATION.
ABOUT VOTERS RIGHTS AND VOTER
REGISTRATION AND ASSIST THEM
WERE RETURNING THE VOTER
REGISTRATION CARDS TO THE
ELECTION OFFICIAL.
THIS BILL WAS APPROVED BY THE
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR -- IT WAS --
A. B. THIRTY ONE FIFTEEN WITH
THREE TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY TO SUPPORT OF AB
SEVENTY SEVEN ARE WILL BE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE NEW WAY
OF LIFE AND THE ACLU.
THE MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BERNIE
STONES ARE FROM A VOTING RIGHTS
ATTORNEY WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA.
ACLU'S PLEASE A SUPPORT AB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD REDUCE
BARRIERS TO DEMOCRACY FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN JAIL BUT WHO
NONETHELESS OF THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
MAJORITY OF THESE ARE THE VOTERS
OF COLOR.
HERE'S CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN GREAT
STRIDES TO BUILD MORE FAIR
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN A MORE
INCLUSIVE ELECTORATE.
THANKS TO SOME OF THESE REFORMS
TODAY PRACTICALLY ALL ADULT
CITIZENS IN COUNTY JAILS HAVE
THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
TRIAL AND SENTENCED ALIKE.
NONETHELESS THE EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
COUNTY JAILS FACE A UNIQUE SET
OF OBSTACLES WHEN THEY REACH FOR
THE BALLOT BOX WE WERE RECENTLY
CONTACTED FOR EXAMPLE B A MAN
IN A LOCAL JAIL.
WHO IS DISENFRANCHISES IN THE
LAST ELECTION BECAUSE HE WAS
DENIED ACCESS TO A PAN?
AB SEVENTY SEVEN WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY JAILS TO
OVERCOME THESE HURDLES.
THE BILL ADDRESS OUT REACH TO
THE DIVERSE RANGE OF PROGRAMMING
THAT COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
ALREADY PROVIDE IN COUNTY JAILS
FROM LEGAL AID IN EDUCATION TO
SOBRIETY SUPPORT AND RELIGIOUS
SERVICES.
AS WITH OTHER VOLUNTEER PROGRAM
SHERIFF'S RETAIN THE RIGHT TO
DENY INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS OF A
ORGANIZATIONS IF THEY BOTH HAVE
A REASONABLE BASIS TO BELIEVE.
THAT THOSE INDIVIDUALS ARE
PRESENT A RISK TO THE SECURITY
OF THE INSTITUTION.
AND AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
PROVIDE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO DECIDE
HOW VOTER OUTREACH PROGRAM
SHOULD LOOK IN THEIR JAILS.
THE LA COUNTY JAIL VOTING
PROGRAM FOR INSTANCE -- SHARES
COLLABORATE WITH COUNTY ORGANISE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS TO PROVIDE
TRAINED VOLUNTEERS.
THAT HELP WITH SUPERVISED VOTER
REGISTRATION SUPPORT IN JAIL DAY
ROOMS DISTRIBUTORS TRACKED WITH
AND MEET BOOKING NUMBERS.
AND TO COLLECT COMPLETE BALLOTS
ON ELECTION DAY.
THESE PARTNERSHIPS WORK LAST
YEAR COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS
HELPED REGISTER OVER THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND RETURN OVER
A THOUSAND BALLOTS FROM INSIDE
LA COUNTY JAILS.
WE ASK THAT YOU INSURE
CALIFORNIANS DON'T LOSE THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL VOTING RIGHTS
BECAUSE A PRACTICAL BARRIERS
INSIDE JAILS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT I THANK YOU AND GOOD
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS OF MY
NAME IS THEIR SEPARATE ON THE
POLICY MANAGER FOR LEGAL SERVICE
FOR PRISON WITH CHILDREN.
MARTHA PROBLEM OF ALL OF US NINE
AND I'M FORMING COURSE RATED --
I HAVE THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
LEADING A VOTING RIGHTS -- FOR
MY ORGANIZATION -- AND I'M
PLEASED TO THE EMPLOYEES TO
TESTIFY HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN I'M ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT OF OUR SISTER
ORGANIZATION A NEW WAY OF LIFE
WAS ALSO A SPONSOR OF US.
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND SO ARE AB
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN AS MODEST
STANDARDS TO EXISTING LAWS WHICH
CURRENTLY ALLOWS ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE VOTER EDUCATION IN
THE JAILS. TO INSURE FAIRNESS
CONSISTENCY AROUND THE PROCESS
AND PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY.
THE BILL ALSO STREAMLINED
STREAMLINES DATA SHARING
REGARDING VOTER ITS ABILITY.
WHAT THE SECRETARY OF STATE
VOTING IS A FUNDAMENTAL
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT?
UNDERSTANDING HOW THE VOTING
PROCESS WORKS AND HAVING ABILITY
TO VOICE COMMUNITY SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION FOR ELECTED OFFICIALS
AND POLICIES THAT IMPACT THE
COMMUNITIES IS A VITAL COMP COMP
COMPONENT. FOR CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE AND WHO
HAVE BEEN INCARCERATED
CALIFORNIA COURTS TO RACE AGAIN
APPROXIMATE EIGHTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
IN ITS JAILS MANY CALIFORNIA'S
INVOLVED OR IMPACT ABOUT THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE
CONFUSED ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE
VOTING RIGHTS EITHER BECAUSE OF
MISINFORMATION OR LACK OF
INFORMATION.
THANKS THE REASON CLARIFICATIONS --
BY AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY SIX
DOCTOR WEAPONS BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN MANY OF THEM
ARE ELIGIBLE TO VOTE AND
REGISTER TO VOTE ON BY PROVIDING
CAN FIT THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
ORGANIZATION PROVIDING VOTER
EDUCATION IN THE JAIL.
AND STREAMLINING A DATA SHARING
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WILL BE AN
ADDITIONAL STEP FORWARD IN
HELPING OUR POPULATION A
POPULATION THAT HAS HISTORICALLY
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
AND PARTICIPATE AND PART AND AND
PARTICIPATION BY PROVIDING THEM
WITH CRITICAL INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE REGARDING THEIR
VOTING RIGHTS FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE SUPPORT AB SEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN AND WE ACTUALLY AYE
VOTE.
ON HIS BILL.
THANK YOU AND OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IF SOMEONE THE LONG ON BEHALF OF
SECRETARY STATE ALEX BUT THE IN
SUPPORT.
SELENA PRIOR CALIFORNIA STATE IN
THE PLACE TO BE IN SUPPORT.
SHARON STONE THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DR RUBBER MINISTERS CIVIL RIGHTS
AND HUMAN RIGHTS SOME SUPPORT.
RIGHT ROCKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COURSE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS WERE MORE OR LESS A
TWEENER WE'RE AT SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION -- BECAUSE WE
HAVE TO PROCESS CONCERNS ABOUT
THIS BILL THAT WE'RE STILL
WORKING WITH THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON OF THIS
CONCERN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- IN OPPOSITION.
THE SPREAD OF OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MR CAM MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUCH LOWER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
WE HAVE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHORS OFFICE AND IN YEARS
PAST AS WELL -- EXPRESSING ARE
ARE WHY WE OPPOSE THIS BILL --
WE CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THE
DESIRE ONTO HAD INMATES
PARTICIPATE IN THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS -- WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL LARGELY IGNORES WHAT'S
ALREADY BEEN GOING ON AS
MENTIONED BY AT THE SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL -- WE ALREADY HAVE
IT PRETTY ON THE SHARE MOST
SHERIFF'S OFFICES ALREADY HAVE A
PRETTY PROACTIVE -- PROCESS IN
THEIR JAILS -- BAD WE BELIEVE
THAT ALLOWING PERSONS AND GROUPS
INTO JAILS AS REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL -- WOULD WOULD CRY STAFF
TIME AND RESOURCES BECAUSE OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE THESE GROUPS
THE COMMAND THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ESCORTED AND THEY
REQUIRE SUPERVISION -- AND THESE
ALL REQUIRE ON RESOURCES AND WE
ARE SO WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BURDENSOME NATURE OF
THE NOTICE AND COMMENT
PROCEDURES THAT ARE OUTLINED IN
THE BILL.
AND FINALLY WE JUST WANNA SAY
THAT LIMITING A JAIL STABILITY
FOR CRUDE CRUDE CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS OR GROUPS BASED ON
THE RISK AT THIS GONNA BE
CREATED BY PERSONAL CONTACT WITH
INMATES -- IGNORES ANY OTHER
SAFETY CONCERNS THAT MIGHT BE
RAISED ABOUT THE PERSON IF HE OR
SHE DOES NOT PERSONALLY INTERACT
WITH INMATES BUT NEVERTHELESS.
HAS ACCESS TO THE JAIL AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE MUST CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE THIS POLICY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BUT IF IT STATE FOR
JUST SECOND MAY HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS THANKS SPREAD.
I YES I'M WITH THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA AND
WE OPPOSED AB -- SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WE BELIEVE THAT IT WOULD
INVADE THE PRIVACY OF THE
INMATES AND THESE INSTITUTIONS
WOULD EXPOSE THEM TO POLITICAL
AND PEER GROUP PRESSURE.
OF WE BELIEVE THE TENANTS OF
SEVEN EIGHT SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
PROVIDE THE FOR THE VIOLATION OF
CIVIL RIGHTS OF THESE FUTURE
VOTERS.
AND WOULD SUBJECT THEM TO
POTENTIAL MANIPULATION DUE TO
THE NATURE OF THE INSTITUTIONAL
SITUATION.
IN ADDITION THE BILL WOULD OPEN
THE DOOR FOR THE REGISTRATION OF
NON CITIZENS CRIMINALIZING THEM
FURTHER AND IN YOUR VOCAL BILLY
HARMING THOSE.
ON A LEGITIMATE PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP.
WE BELIEVE THAT OCEAN -- OPEN
REGISTRATION DRIVES IN A
RESTRICTED GROUP SITUATION WOULD
MAKE PRIVACY IMPOSSIBLE
REGISTRANTS WOULD BE WOULD
EXPERIENCE UNACCEPTABLE PRESSURE
FROM POWER STRUCTURE.
IN HERE AMONG INMATES AND REFUGE
RED RETRIBUTION WOULD BE CERTAIN.
FOR A PRISONER WHO CHOSE TO
REGISTER IN A MANNER
INCONSISTENT WITH THE DICTATES
OF THE DOMINANT INDIVIDUALS
WITHIN THE INSTITUTION.
ACCORDING TO THE CONGRESSIONAL
REGISTER THE POPULATION FOR NON
CITIZENS IN U. S. PRISONS IS
ESTIMATED TO BE 20% 27% A 94% OF
THOSE.
ARE IN COUNTY COUNTIES ILLEGAL
IN THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
IT IS LOGICAL TO ASSUME THAT
THOSE PERCENTAGE PERCENTAGES FOR
JAILS IN JUVENILE DETENTION
CENTERS WOULD BE COMPARE OF ALL.
AND THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
THESE NON CITIZENS WOULD BE
SWEPT UP IN AN ALL INCLUSIVE
REGISTRATION DRIVE.
SUCH AS WOULD BE ALLOWED UNDER
AB.
SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR GROUP
PRESSURE IN FEAR OF RETALIATION
WOULD KEEP THEM FROM SPEAKING UP
AND REFUSING TO REGISTER IN
ORDER TO RESPECT THE LAW.
THE SITUATION VICTIMIZERS THE
INMATES BUT ALSO VERY A LAWFUL
VOTER OF EVERY LAWFUL VOTER IN
THE STATE.
EVERY VOTE CAST BY INDIVIDUAL
UNLAWFULLY REGISTERED WOULD
DILUTE THE VOTES OF THOSE
LEGITIMATE CITIZEN VOTERS.
INCLUDING THOSE OF THE NEW AND
LEGITIMATE INMATE REGISTRANTS.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN PROVIDES
NO STRUCTURE TO PERVERT PREVENT
INAPPROPRIATE REGISTRATION OR
PROTECTION OF THOSE WHO CANNOT
LAWFULLY PARTICIPATE.
NOR THOSE WHO SIMPLY CHOOSE NOT
TO PARTICIPATE.
THE LEGISLATURE WOULD BETTER
SERVE THE CITIZEN INMATES WHO
TEND TO BE A LOW PROPENSITY
VOTERS BY PROVIDING CIVIC
EDUCATION.
DURING THEIR INCARCERATION
INCLUDING ENCOURAGING THEM TO
BECOME ACTIVE CITIZENS.
PROVIDING THEM NONPARTISAN
INFORMATION AND INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW TO REGISTER ONLINE IN
PRIVACY -- I THINK YOU JUST
READING THE LETTER NOW RIGHT YES
RIGHT.
OF THE COUNTRY.
TO MANY MET LEASE MINIS OPINION
WE ACTUALLY CAN READ OKAY WELL
ALL RIGHT -- IF THERE'S ANYTHING
YOU WANT TO ADD OKAY TO THE
LETTER OKAY NOISE IS SELF
EXPLANATORY WE WERE ABLE TO
SUBMIT THIS LETTER EARLY FOR YOU
TO READ IT SO I JUST WANTED.
TO GET INTO THE RECORD ALL RIGHT
ANYTHING YOU WANT TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL THAT ARE JUST LAST
PARAGRAPH IS IT SO YOU'RE GOOD
OKAY.
THANK YOU LET ME LET ME ASK SOME
QUESTIONS BUT ALL FIRST DEFERRED
ANYBODY ELSE THE NIELSEN -- AND
ALSO LET ME ASK OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE WE AFTER --
ASSEMBLYMAN GIBSON CONCLUDES
HERE WE HAVE ASSEMBLY WOMAN CAN
SALAS AND SHE IS OUR LAST
AUTHORS SO IF YOU ARE SENATOR
HERTZBERG SENATOR.
LIVES BEEN HERE SENATOR STERN --
BE A GOOD TIME TO COME DOWN TO
COMMITTEE.
SO LET ME ASK YOU -- ASSEMBLYMAN
GIBSON IN TERMS OF THE PROGRAM.
YOU'RE GONNA CORRECT ME HERE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IS THAT WHEN
SOMEONE FROM ONE OF THE VOTER
REGISTRATION ORGANIZATIONS COMES
TO THE FACILITY.
THEY WOULD SIMPLY -- BASICALLY
ALERT THOSE WHO ARE THEIR THEIR
PRESENT AND IT IT IT'S UP TO THE
INCARCERATED PERSON TO DETERMINE
WHETHER HE OR SHE WANTS TO VISIT
WITH THAT ORGANIZATION IS THAT
RIGHT APPS ABSOLUTELY IS.
PURELY VOLUNTARILY SO THERE'S NO
COERCIVE ACTIVITY THEY'RE NOT
FORCED TO COME TO A MEETING ROOM
ANY SUCH THING IS THAT RIGHT
ABSOLUTELY NOT THEY'RE NOT --
FORCE TO COME TO ANY MEETING
ROOM -- THEY CAN REJECT --
SEEING ANY INDIVIDUAL
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION THAT IS
NONPARTISAN ALSO I WANT TO MAKE --
MAY HAVE TO OPT IN RIGHT OPTING
OUT THAT IS CORRECT RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT AND LET ME AS THE IS
IT MISS MASTER.
THANK MODULAR MODULAR -- ARE
THERE ANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THAT COME INTO THE
FACILITIES FOR EXAMPLE RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS THAT -- MAKES
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO MEET
WITH THOSE WHO ARE INCARCERATED
I PRESUME THAT THE IT IS YES.
SO SO THE RATHER ORGANIZATIONS
THAT THE DO THAT AND HOW DOES
THIS YEAR OF DEAL WITH THE
CONCERNS YOU JUST REYES
CONCERNING SECURITY AND THE LIKE
WITH THE OTHER. FOR EXAMPLE
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS WELL
THOSE WOULD BE -- DONE ON ON
COUNTY BY COUNTY BASIS AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU WHAT EACH
SHERIFF DIES TO HANDLE THOSE
PARTICULAR SITUATIONS WITH FAITH
GROUPS OR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
FOUR EIGHT FOR EXAMPLE A A
COMING IN ON EACH COUNTY HANDLES
THOSE DIFFERENTLY.
SO I DON'T KNOW ANY COUNTY BY
COUNTY BASIS HOW THEY DO THOSE
SO THAT'S A GOOD EXAMPLE A SO.
SO GIVE SAID THAT DOES THIS BILL
GIVE.
ANY PRIORITY OR GIVE ANY
PREFERENCE TO GIVE ANY SPECIAL
TREATMENT TO VOTER REGISTRATION
ORGANIZATIONS AS OPPOSED TO
OTHER GROUPS LIKE LIKE A NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT IS GIVEN SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES THERE THE SHERIFF
DEPARTMENT WILL AND HAVE ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED BY ALLOWING
NONPROFITS TO GO IN TO DO THE
WORK.
PRESS ONLY THIS TAKING PLACE IN
OUR JAILS RIGHT NOW AND SO WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT THIS
WAS WHAT WE HAVE THIS PARTICULAR
BILL SO THEY ARE GETTING POORER
ANY KIND OF SPECIAL TREATMENT.
THE COME INSIDE JUST THERE WAS
IN YOUR LINE OF QUESTIONING --
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS OTHERS HAVE THE
RIGHT TO GO INSIDE -- AND WITHIN
THE OF STAFFING THIS IS DOES NOT
INCREASE STAFFING LEVEL FOR TIM
TO REMOVE OF THE SHARES OFFER
WHATEVER THE ELSE THEY'RE DOING
TO COME AND DO THIS KIND OF WORK.
IS ALREADY SET UP IN THE JAILS
RIGHT NOW.
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY SORT OF
SPECIAL ACCOMMODATION SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE REQUIRE SPECIAL ROOM
IS REQUIRES AT ANY SORT OF
PETITIONING ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
DO YOU KNOW.
NOT. FOR SIX THAT WOULD PROBABLY
ALSO BE DEPENDENT ON THE COUNTY
BUT THE BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN
GIVES THE COUNTIES THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DESIGN A PROGRAM
IN A WAY THAT WORKS BEST FOR
THEIR INSTITUTIONS -- PERSONALLY
I SPENT SEVERAL YEARS GOING TO
SAN FRANCISCO JAIL AND OTHER
COUNTY JAILS TEACHING CLASSES ON
MARKET CLEARANCE AND FAMILY LAW.
AND THOSE ARE DONE IS DIRECTLY
IN THE POD WITH STAFF THAT WAS
ALREADY GOING TO BE.
STAFFING THAT POD.
M. THE CONCERNS RAISED ABOUT NON
CITIZENS BEING REGISTERED HOW
HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS THAT SOON
GIPSON -- TO PREVENT NONSENSE
YOU CAN YOU CAN'T VOTE IF YOU'RE
A NON CITIZEN YOU DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TO TO VOTE.
SO THEREFORE YOU KNOW TO FILL
OUT A VOTER REGISTRATION CARD.
IT'LL BE NULL AND VOID.
IT WOULD THERE BE ANY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN FOR EXAMPLE AT A NON
CITIZEN INMATE.
FILLING OUT A CARD VERSUS
SOMEONE ON THE STREET.
IN TERMS OF THE CHECKS AND
BALANCES THAT THE HOUSES.
ARE.
AND WHAT ABOUT FELONS THERE ARE
FELONS WHO ARE INCARCERATED IN
SOME COUNTY JAILS HOW WOULD.
HOW WOULD THEY BE -- PRECLUDED
OR EXCLUDED.
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SERVING
REALIGNMENT FELONY SENTENCES FOR
NON SERIOUS NON VIOLENT OR NON
SEXUAL.
FELONIES ARE PERMITTED TO VOTE
IN CALIFORNIA SO THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN COUNTY JAILS OR NOT
ALLOWED TO VOTE WERE ADULTS
ADDISON'S.
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE SERVING STATE
FELONY SENTENCES UNDER CONTRACT
WITH COUNTY JAILS WHICH IS A
VERY A VERY SMALL MINORITY OF
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN COUNTY
JAILS AND THE BUT THE JAIL AND
THAT INDIVIDUAL SHOULD KNOW.
WHO THEY ARE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE IN COUNTY JAIL SCANDAL.
GLOBAL THAT RAISES ANOTHER
QUESTION IT IS THIS YEAR FOR THE
JAILER REQUIRED THEN -- TO DO
SOME SORT OF SORTING AS BETWEEN
THOSE WHO ARE FELONS OF THOSE OR
NON FELONS.
THE BILL DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT
NOW.
OKAY WELL IS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD -- WE WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF MAKING SURE THAT
FELONS DODD DAHLE REGISTER IF
THERE'S SOME OTHER MECHANISM I'M
ALBUM TO SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
BUT BUT LIKE TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION -- ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT.
THOSE WHO WOULD BE LEGALLY
INELIGIBLE TO VOTE SOMEHOW COULD
HAVE SOME.
OF ADVANTAGE FOR EXAMPLE BASED
ON THIS PROGRAM LET ME ALSO SAY
CENTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
QUESTION.
IF A PERSON REGISTER TO VOTE
pVOTER REGISTRATION CARDS WILL GO
TO THE ELECTION OFFICIALS.
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS WOULD DO
WHAT THEY ALWAYS DO AND THEY
WILL VERIFY WHETHER THAT A
PERSON ELIGIBLE TO VOTE.
AND A PERSON REGISTER TO VOTE
WHO'S ON ELIGIBLE VOTER THEN
THAT WILL COUNSEL THEM OUT FROM
PARTICIPATING IN THAT IN ANY
ELECTION.
ALL RIGHT ANYBODY OPPOSITION ONE
RESPOND IN MY QUESTIONS.
NOW AGAIN I WE FEEL THAT THIS IS
A MAN.
THE BILL REQUIRES CERTAIN STEPS
pRESOURCES THAT SHARE SIMPLY
DON'T HAVE TO MEET THESE
REQUIREMENTS LET ME LET ME GO
BACK TO MY ORIGINAL QUESTION
THOUGH WHAT WHAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES WILL BE REQUIRED FOR
THIS PROGRAM.
THIS ORGANIZATION AS OPPOSED TO
A A OR RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATION I
CAN PROVIDE THAT FOR YOU ALL
RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT ALL RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS
JUST CENTER NIELSEN.
DO THE JAILS HAVE A NO HOSTAGE
POLICY SOME OF THEM LIKE CDC ARE.
IN OTHER WORDS IF YOU COME IN
YOU HAVE TO SIGN A NO HOSTAGE.
THE KNOWLEDGE MINT THEY DO.
AND WOULD THEY NOT.
BE THE COUNTY. TO SOME DEGREE
LIABLE.
IF SOMETHING HAPPENED.
A RIOT THAT SOMEONE GOT INJURED
ONE OF THESE VOTER REGISTRATION
PEOPLE.
I THINK THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
BUT WOULD THERE BE ANY
DISTINCTION -- THE DISCERN
ELSE'S QUESTION OF BETWEEN FOR
EXAMPLE SOMEONE WHO'S THERE FOR
RELIGIOUS PURPOSES -- AND AS
POLLS SOME OF THEIRS FOR VOTER
REGISTRATION PURPOSE IN TERMS OF
LIABILITY OR HOSTAGE TAKING.
I'M NOT AWARE OF THAT BUT I
WOULD HAVE TO CHECK INTO THAT
FOR YOU.
HE WOULD SIGN THE SAME WAIVER I
WOULD EXPECT IS THAT RIGHT
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THE RIGHT -- BILL'S BEEN MOVED
OF SEVEN NUMBER GIVE SOME WAS
LIKE CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT IN
WILL WITH THE THERE'S A THERE'S
A ONE QUESTION REMAINING THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO TALK ABOUT.
ART.
OF BETTER SIR TO BE CALL THE
ROLL MOTION IS TO PASS A SET A
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE NUMBER
HI.
I'M BURKE AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG LEYVA LEYVA
AYE STERN.
ALL RIGHT -- WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN.
SO -- ASSEMBLY WOMAN GONZALEZ
THE MOON GOOD THOUGHTS IS THE
LAST AUTHORED TWO DAY.
SO WE NEED.
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
COME DOWN.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE CAUCUS IN TWELVE MINUTES
SO.
BE MINDFUL THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ ABSOLUTELY RIGHT I
START WITH AB.
SIX EIGHTY ONE SB SIX EIGHTY ONE
YES OKAY AB -- SIXTY EIGHTY ONE
IS A SIMPLE BILL TO TRY TO SOLVE
SOME THE CONFUSION AND AND VOTER
ANGST -- THAT WE SAW DURING THE
LAST PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY WE
HAVE CONFUSING ROLES -- IF
YOU'RE NO PARTY PREFERENCE VOTER
YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PARTISAN
PRIMARY -- BUT YOU STILL HAVE TO
TAKE AN ACTIVE STEP OR RE
REGISTER -- TO TO PARTICIPATE IN
AT LEAST ONE PARTY'S PRIMARY SO
WHAT THIS DOES -- IS A IN ORDER
SOLVE THIS IS TO NOTIFY THOSE
VOTERS THREE TIMES -- TO ALLOW
THEM THAT.
PROPER NOTICE PRIOR TO RECEIVING
AN ABSENTEE BALLOT THAT -- THE
WITH NO PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES
ON IT THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO IN
FACT TAKE THAT EXTRA STEP -- WE
ALSO -- ARE DRESSING A PROBLEM
WITH -- CONDITIONAL REGISTRATION
AND THAT IF YOU NEED TO CHANGE
YOUR PARTY OR ON YOUR ADDRESS.
ON THE DAY OF ELECTION I YOU YOU
HAVE -- TO VOTE PROVISIONALLY
BUT THIS WOULD ALLOW YOU TO DO
SO -- AND CAST ACTUAL BALLOT
THOSE ARE TWO THINGS THIS BILL
DOES IT THINK IT MAKES SENSE IT
GIVES THAT EIGHT CLEAR --
UNDERSTANDING FOR ESPECIALLY
NONPARTISAN VOTERS IN OUR
PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT.
THANK YOU THE IF ANY WALKING WE
HAVE THE SECRETARY STATE FOR
REASONS STATED WE SUPPORT THE
BILL ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS A WELL
I'M SORRY STRIKE THAT -- OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SHARON STONE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION -- MISS BRITAIN.
WERE MISS BRITAIN WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO GET YOU A SEAT A LITTLE
CLOSER BUT COME ON UP YES.
WHILE YOU'RE MAKING YOUR WAY UP
YOUR MISPRINT LET ME ASK THE
AUTHOR A QUESTION THIS ONLY
APPLIES PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARIES
IS THAT RIGHT THAT'S RIGHT OUR
THE ONLY PROBLEM WE HAVE WITH.
BUT NOT BE ABLE CAST ABOUT AN
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF SORRY
REALLY QUICKLY TO CLARIFY THE
PROCESS OF UPDATING YOUR
INFORMATION TO KEEP IT ACCURATE
IS ONLY FOR THE VOTERS WHO ARE
ALREADY REGISTERED IN THAT
COUNTY.
OR IN THAT SPECIFIC PRECINCTS SO
THERE COULD BE NO CHANCE OF
SOMEONE WHO ALREADY RECEIVED A
VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT.
AND IS EITHER NOT SURRENDERING
IT OR THERE IS NOT A
COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT -- BELL IS THE
ONLY ONE CAST THERE CAN BE NO
OTHER CIRCUMSTANCE OF WHICH
THERE ARE TWO BALLOTS PROVIDED
TO THAT PERSON.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
MISS BRITAIN AND GIVE YOU A
LETTER.
RIGHT SO NOW I WON'T READ IT OF
WELL OKAY THANK YOU.
AND BY THE WAY I I APPRECIATE
THAT THANK YOU DO PUT YOUR
TESTIMONY RUNNING -- IN AGAIN
COUNTRY TO WHAT SOME MAY BELIEVE
I AM CONFIDENT WE ALL CAN READ.
AND SOTO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
YOU WANTED TO ADD TO WHAT WHAT
YOU PROVIDED TO US IN WRITING.
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY -- A COUPLE
THINGS BASICALLY THE THE
ARGUMENT BOILED BOILS DOWN TO
THE THE FACT THAT.
OF THIS PROCEDURE IS ALREADY
BEEN DONE THE VOTER IS ALREADY
BEING NOTIFIED.
AND ONCE IS PROBABLY ENOUGH TO
NOTIFY THE PERSON AND THE DOING
IT THREE TIMES.
IS THE UNDUE BURDEN FINANCIALLY
AND LOGISTICALLY FOR THE
REGISTER VOTERS IS CLOSE TO
ELECTION SO.
WE JUST FEEL IT IT'S UNNECESSARY
AND COST.
COSTS A LOT OF MONEY.
FEELS LIKE AN APPROPRIATIONS
QUESTION.
ALL RIGHT -- ANYTHING ELSE ANY
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
NO QUESTIONS OF CENTER LABOR
MOVES -- WHICH I CLOSE THEM
RESPECT LAST WHEN I MET ALL
RIGHT.
UNANSWERED IF YOU CALL THE ROLL
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG LEYVA LEYVA
AYE STERN.
SO A NOW I'M NOW PLEADING I WAS
REQUESTING BEFORE BUT I'M NOW
PLEADING FOR OTHERS TO COME DOWN.
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
CLOSE THE ROLE FOR CAUCUS HERE
MOMENTARILY SO.
THE MOON GONZALEZ YOU HAVE THE
FINAL. SEVEN SEVENTY THREE AND I
WILL ALSO PLEADING FOR SENATORS
TO COME DOWN SO MY BILLS CAN GET
THROUGH -- THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I DON'T WANT TO SLOW DOWN
BUT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE WILL EQUIP OUR YOUNG
ADULTS BECOME ELECTORALLY ENGAGE
CITIZENS BY REQUIRING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT VOTER
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
WHAT WE KNOW TODAY AS SO MANY OF
US YOU AND I PROBABLY LEARNED TO
VOTE BY A?
SENIOR PARENTS FILED BY POSSIBLY
GOING WITH OUR PARENTS ABOUT AND
WE'VE SO MANY STUDENTS TODAY WHO --
HAVEN'T HAD THAT EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS -- ARE
INELIGIBLE TO VOTE OR OR HAVE
NOT VOTED SO WE LITERALLY NEED
TO TEACH YOUNG PEOPLE AFTER
WE'VE DONE ALL THIS WORK TO
REGISTER THEM IN AND TO ENSURE
THAT IT WE CAN REGISTER THEM IN
ANY THE WAY WE NEED TO ACTUALLY
TEACH THEM THE MECHANICS.
OF HOW TO VOTE THIS IS -- IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND LOCAL AND
COUNTY OFFICIALS SO THAT THESE --
NEW VOTERS CAN ONCE THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE AT EIGHTEEN FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT THEIR THAT THEY
KNOW HOW TO GET TO ACCESS
NONPARTISAN INFORMATION HOW TO
ACCESS THE POLLING LOCATION OR
VOTE BY MAIL WHAT THAT BALLOT
LOOKS LIKE AND HOW.
TO PROPERLY VOTE -- ALTHOUGH I
THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE.
DON'T CONSIDER THIS A AN ISSUE --
THE NUMBER OF YOUNG VOTERS I'VE
TALKED TO HAVE BEEN INTIMIDATED
BY THE VOTING PROCESS OUT OF
JUST A BASIC CIVICS LESSON --
THAT COULD BE SOLVED AND THAT'S
WHAT E'RE HOPING TO DO HERE
RESPECT LAST FOR AN AYE VOTE
HAVE A COUPLE PEOPLE IN SUPPORT.
A SALOON BEFORE YOU YOU KNOW I'M
ALSO ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
YOU OF READ MY MIND YES THAT IS
VERY PRESSION OF YOU OF ALL
RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF A BUT IT US ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL.
AS MENTIONED BY ASSEMBLY WOMAN
GONZALEZ -- MANY OF THE NEW
VOTERS MAY BE UNAWARE OF THE
MULTIPLE WAYS THEY CAN CAST A
BALLET AND MAY FIND IT DIFFICULT
TO UNDERSTAND THE VOTING PROCESS.
FROM THE STATE WITH PERSPECTIVE
THE SUPER INTENDANT BELIEVES
MORE CAN BE DONE TO SUPPORT OUR
SCHOOLS AND EDUCATING OUR
STUDENTS ABOUT THE VOTING
PROCESS.
AB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE WOULD
ENHANCE ALIFORNIA'S VOTER
EDUCATION EFFORTS.
AND WOULD PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
THE KNOWLEDGE AND RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO BECOME.
ELECTORALLY ENGAGE CITIZENS I
RESPECT PAST THREE AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING PATTY HER ON BEHALF
OF THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT APART CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL -- THE DISTRICT FEELS VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THE NEED TO
EDUCATE YOUNG VOTERS AS PROBABLY
THE LARGEST DISENFRANCHISED OF
ARE VOTING POPULATION -- AND WE
THINK THAT IT AB SEVEN SEVENTY
THREE ADVANCES THAT -- THAT
PURPOSE WE KNOW THAT OF IT
EDUCATING YOUNG STUDENTS ON HOW
TO VOTE IN THE PROCESS OF VOTING
GIVES THEM IMPROVE EITHER GIVES
THEM OR IMPROVED HERSELF --
SENSE OF AGENCY -- AS CITIZENS
IN THIS DEMOCRACY AND FOR THAT
WE ASK FOR YOUR EYES BUT I
THOUGH.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
AND SUPPORT. FIFTY MARK ON
BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY STATE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT.
SURELY DAM HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL VERSUS THE ASIAN IN
SUPPORT.
HEY GROWTH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA IN
SHARON STONE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT -- CARES WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED JUST OF ONE
FINAL COMMENT I I THINK THAT
LACK OF EDUCATION LACK OF CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT IS THE GREATEST
THREAT TO OUR DEMOCRACY I
CONGRATULATE YOU FOR BRING THIS
FORWARD REALLY IMPORTANT ALL
RIGHT -- THEM SECRETARY.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
NUMBER.
I'M BURKE AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN OBSCENE HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA HI STERN.
RIGHT WHAT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN -- WE YEAH.
SO LET'S LET'S DO THIS LET'S GO
THROUGH IT ONCE -- WE NEED A
MOTION ON AB -- THIRTY NINE
CALLER.
OF I'M SORRY -- FIFTY NINE OKAY
SO MOVED OF TO CALL THE ROLL ON
AB FIFTY NINE KALRA.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS AMBER.
HI AMBER HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG LEYVA.
LEYVA EYES STERN.
AND THEN THE TAXES AB TEN THIRTY
NINE BY SOME REDUCE.
DAVIS DYSLEXIA IS REALLY -- AT
TEN THIRTY SIX I WE ARE CURRY.
IT'S BEEN MOVED MOTION IS. TO
PASS TO SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AMBER I NUMBER HI
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
IT'S AB TEN THIRTY SIX BY
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I RIGHT.
HI LABOR ARE LEYVA AYE STERN.
ALL OF THE UP.
ALL RIGHT -- HELLO.
IT IS WILL STAR STILL NEED TO
WRITE IT WILL LEAVE IT OPEN THE
ROLE OPEN BUT ALL RIGHT.
JUST.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S WAIT JUST FOR HERE'S HENRY
STERN CENTER STERN IS HERE OKAY
PERFECT SO.
WE'RE GONNA GO THROUGH OF THE
ENTIRE LIST AND THEY WERE GONNA
CLOSE THE ROLE [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SCA ONE ALLEN MOTION IS THE
ADOPTION RE REFER TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CRIME VOTE IS TO
ICE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN.
HI HEY THAT'S FOUR ZERO AB FORTY
NINE CERVANTES MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO EYES AND ONE KNOW WHAT THE
CHAIR VOTING HI.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN.
STERN I FOR ONE I BILLS OUT AB
FIFTY NINE KALRA MOTION IS DUE
PASSED THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
CRIME VOTE IS TO AYE AYES AND
ONE NO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG GUYS STERN.
STERN I WAS [inaudible]
FOUR TO ONE BILLS OUT.
AB TWO A ONE CERVANTES MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATE -- THE SENATOR STERN --
THE CLEAN MONEY IS WITHDRAWN
THEIR OPPOSITION THERE'D BEEN
SOME AMENDMENTS MADE THE LAST
COUPLE OF HOURS SO.
NUMBER FOUR FILE NUMBER FOUR YES.
ALL RIGHT.
AND MOTION IS TO PASS IS AMENDED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
LOTUS TO WHITES.
NO ONE NO WITH HER VOTING HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D STERN.
STERN I ORDER ONE OR ONE BILLS
OUT.
AB TWO TWENTY BONTA MOTION IS TO
PASS CURRENT LOTUS THREE EYES NO
NOSE HERTZBERG.
I STERN.
STERN HI.
I'M AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE MORELAND
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CRUMBLED AS ONE
ONLINE.
NUMBER.
HI NUMBER HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN.
STERN HI.
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR CALL THE
CONSENT CALENDAR OKAY TWO ITEMS
ON CONSENT CALENDAR A. B. SIX
TWENTY THREE BERMAN.
AND AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE BONTA
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
BOB HERTZBERG AYE STERN STERN.
AB EIGHT SIX SIX EIGHTY ONE
GONZALEZ MOTION IS TO PASS TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT
LOTUS TO WIFE.
AND ONE KNOW WHAT THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN.
AB.
SIX EIGHTY ONE STERN. NINE FORTY
ONE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB SEVEN
THIRTY BERMAN MOTIONS TO PASS TO
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE.
IT JUST A HEADS UP THERE'S BEEN --
SIGNIFICAN AMENDMENTS HERE THE
TEARS VOTING I'D.
YEAH WHILE ALSO STERN CARES
ISLAND BUT ACTUALLY -- HERTZBERG
DOESN'T I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
RIGHT [inaudible]
THE NUMBER.
HI AMBER HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG GUYS STERN
[inaudible]
AM.
AB OKAY DOES IS THE ITEM NUMBER
TEN OKAY AB SEVEN SEVENTY THREE
GONZALEZ MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE AS TO WHY THE NO
KNOWS WITH THE CHAIR VOTING HI.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN [inaudible]
STERN I WELL.
AB SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN GIPSON
[inaudible]
NO.
I'M SORRY YES THE END OF YOUR
YOUR RIGHT THE RUN.
MOTION IS THE PATTERSON THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE IS TO RISE AND ONE NO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN STERN HI.
HE ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT SIXTY
FOUR MULLIN.
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CRIME VOTE IS ONE
TIME.
NUMBER.
NUMBER I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG ICE TIME.
STERN.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB NINE SIXTY
THREE PETRIE-NORRIS MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CRIME VOTE IS TWO
WIVES AND ONE KNOW WHAT THE TERM
VOTING I HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I STERN.
HI. FOR THOSE OUT.
AB A I DON'T FOURTEEN AB.
TEN THIRTY SIX YOUR KARIMOV SIN
IS TO PASS TO SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
OUR CURRENT LOTUS THREE AS ONE
NO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I STERN
[inaudible]
STERN HI -- ITEM FIFTEEN AB
ELEVEN FIFTY GLORIA MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS.
BILLS ALSO BEEN AMENDED -- TO
FORTY SIGNATURES FORTY SIXTY
SIGNATURES.
CURRENT VOTE IS TO AYE AYES AND
WHEN NO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN [inaudible]
STERN I THAT IS IT.
I THINK THAT CONCLUDES OUR
BUSINESS.
MANY IS ADJOURNED